Zwei Minuten nach 22 Uhr.
Ja, ähm, drei Minuten nach 22 Uhr.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Menschen, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben, die mir die Zeit gebeten haben. Alex, was du jetzt sagst, ist im Radio zu hören.
Das heißt nicht, dass du den Mund halten sollst, du bist schließlich hier um was zu erzählen. Geschätzte Hörner, hier hört das Chaos Radio Nummer 88 um elektronische Kameraüberwachung oder überhaupt Kameraugen soll es gehen. Was das im Detail bedeutet, werde ich gleich von Frank erfahren. Mit mir im Studium mir, das ist Holger Klein, außerdem der Martin vom CCC, der Nils von der humanistischen Union für die juristischen Fragen und der Jan ebenfalls vom CCC und selbstverständlich Franco vom CCC und der sagt das Thema heute Abend.
Heute im Chaos Radio geht es um Überwachung. Videoüberwachung ist allgegenwärtig und an Kameras in jeder Ecke haben wir uns schon gewöhnt. Oder nicht? Gibt es in der Bevölkerung vielleicht sogar Widerstand gegen eine Überwachung, wie George Orbel sie prophezeit? Wer soll sich eigentlich die Bilderflut von Tausenden von Kameras anschauen? Wie weit ist die Technik, um Bewegungsprofile zu erstellen und um uns auf Schritt und Tritt zu verfolgen? Können wir in Zukunft noch unbeobachtet U-Bahn oder Auto fahren? Schick Fragen und Hinweise zur Sendung an 88 at chaosradio.ccc.de oder schaut auch mal auf die Website chaosradio.ccc.de Und wie immer gilt, denn das ist hier der Blue Moon auf Fritz, wer was zu sagen hat und hier anruft, der wird auch gehört.
0331 70 97 110 Dein Lieblingslied zum Start, Frank?
Nein, vorweg, die Hintenkamera.
Chaosradio 88 auf Fritz ist es, was ihr hört. Heute geht es um Kameraüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum. Unsere Innenminister, zumindest die der Länder, die haben da ja gerade ganz tolle Sachen geplant. Und jede Menge Leute sind im Studio, der Martin vom CTC, Nils von der Humanistischen Union, Jan vom CTC und Frank vom CTC. Warum Frank hier ist, das ist mir klar, weil Frank weiß, wie Radio geht. Aber Martin, warum bist du hier?
Na wir hatten uns im Clubumfeld schon so ein bisschen mit Videoüberwachung beschäftigt gehabt, weil es halt ein permanent aktuelles Thema ist. Und die technischen Entwicklungen schreiten da ja auch voran, sodass halt irgendwie ständig was Neues auf die Tagesordnung kommt. Und ich wollte ein bisschen was zu ÖPNV sagen, wie das damit vernetze.
Öffentlicher Personennahverkehr. Wie kommen eigentlich, bitte erklär mir im Laufe der Sendung noch, wie diese BZ-Reklame auf diese Bildschirme kommt. Ich hab irgendwo mal gelesen, dass das gewähland wird und das finde ich ziemlich sexy, wenn das der Fall wäre.
Da gibt es verschiedene Technologien, da kommen wir auf jeden Fall drauf zu sprechen, weil genau diese Technik ist auch interessant in Bezug auf Videoüberwachung.
Wobei ich finde ja diese komischen Bildschirme fast schlimmer als die Kameras in den U-Bahnen.
Ich sag auch mal, könnt ihr da nicht mal irgendwie vielleicht was von einer deutschen Welle oder irgendwas Seriöses und nicht gerade die BZ nehmen?
Also BZ ist ja nur noch schlimmer als Kurier.
Obwohl, ich mein der Kurier hat die schlimmsten nackten Weiber in der Zeit und das muss man echt mal sagen.
Ich hab's mittlerweile gelernt zu ignorieren des Zeugs.
WVG behauptet, dass 80% der Leute, die in der U-Bahn fahren, das irgendwie toll finden.
Also ich find das total informativ. Wenn du irgendwie keine Zeitung gelesen hast, du in die U-Bahn gehst, dann kannst du dir einfach mal...
Dann bekommst du da auf diesen Fernsehern die seriöseste Information, die du mir wünschen kannst. Michael Jackson beim Kinderpoppen erwischt. Das interessiert mich.
Wollte ich noch mal wissen?
Nee, wollte ich nie wissen. Ich wusste schon immer, dass der Typ krank ist.
Die sollten einen heißen Ticker drauf packen.
Ja, das wär's.
Genau.
Nils, was will die humanistische Union heute Abend hier?
Die humanistische Union beschäftigt sich eigentlich schon seit 20 Jahren mit dem Thema vor allem Datenschutz. Die humanistische Union hat die Datenschutzbewegung wesentlich mit angestoßen damals. Und wir haben das Thema Videoüberwachung eben auch kontinuierlich begleitet. Ich habe als Anwalt eben auch jetzt vor kurzem einen Prozess geführt für einen Mandanten, der gegen Videokameras geklagt hat. Und darüber würde ich gerne auch was erzählen.
Ja, gerne doch. Und Jan, was willst du hier? Hast du Zigaretten mit?
Nee, ich rauche gar nicht.
Ich rauche gar nicht?
Habe ich nicht gesehen. Doch, du hast von geraucht. Ja, also ich beschäftige mich halt irgendwie mit Biometrie hauptsächlich. Und da Videoüberwachung ja irgendwie mit Kameras. Und dann kann man gleich zur Gesichtserkennung überleiten und einfach mal so ein bisschen die Technik beleuchten und was uns da alles noch böses bevorsteht.
Weinen doch nicht, was ist denn Frank?
Na ich wollte eigentlich auch noch ein bisschen was erzählen. Nämlich was euch blüht, wenn ihr so als Autofahrer vielleicht mal irgendwann unterwegs seid und dann in so schönen Kontrollbrücken durchfahrt oder wenn da so Kameras an der Seite stehen, was dann mit den Sachen passiert und wieder gerade zu den aktuellen Bestrebungen sind dazu. Da hat uns nämlich auch der Ulf schon vor der Sendung was geschrieben an die 88.chaosradio.ccc.de und wollte dann auch mal wissen, wie das dann so aussieht, ob die Nummernschilder jetzt automatisch alle abgeglichen werden oder wie das überhaupt funktioniert, ob es da Bewegungsprofile gibt und sowas.
Chaosradio 88 zur Kameraüberwachung des öffentlichen Raumes hier auf Fritz. 0331 70 97 110. Falls ihr die eine oder andere Frage zu diesem ganzen Komplex habt, dürft ihr die selbstverständlich stellen. Wir hätten auch eine Frage an euch.
Nennt uns positive Aspekte der Kameraüberwachung. Warum sollen wir Kameras haben? Was ist der Grund? Es gibt bestimmt tolle viele gute Gründe dafür. Zum Beispiel Gegenspray.
Du sollst dich nicht sagen, das sollen die Hörer sagen. Gute Gründe für Kameraüberwachung von öffentlichen oder halbervieligen Räumen. Ich finde das total toll. Ich auch. Abzuliefern unter 0331 70 97 110. Und der Ali aus Fürstenwalde ist dran.
Hallo?
Einbeiniger? Der Einbeinige sitzt immer an der Hotline. Einbeiniger, wir brauchen einen neuen Ali.
Ali?
Ali ist weg.
0331 70 97 110, falls ihr unser neuer Ali sein wollt. Ich bin ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich. Ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, aber ich bin auch ein bisschen schrecklich, Wir haben einen neuen Ali unter 0331 70 97 110 angerufen.
Ja hallo, ich bin der neue Ali, aber eigentlich heiße Thomas. Und die Vorteile, sag mal so, ich würde sagen, was die in die Nachteile sagen wollen und zwar, ich sehe für mich persönlich keine Nachteile, also in dem Sinne, dass meine Daten irgendwo landen. Ich habe nichts dagegen, dass ich vielleicht auf der Autobahn gescannt werde, weil ich habe nichts zu verbergen und ich habe damit kein Problem. Da haben vielleicht eher Leute mit Problemen, die da eher was zu verbergen haben. Also ich sehe die Sachen an Unbedarf, vielleicht kriege ich heute noch was mit, wo ich vielleicht auch wieder kritischer rangehe.
Also ich habe nichts zu verbergen und ich fühle mich trotzdem nicht wohl damit.
Na gut, ist ja alles subjektiv und Geschmackssache, nicht?
Ja sicher, wo führt das hin? Also fragen wir unseren Juristen, oder Nils? Wo führt das hin, wenn jeder sagt, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, mich können sie überwachen?
Ja, jetzt aus rechtlicher Sicht ist das so, dass dieser Spruch, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, natürlich eigentlich unsere Rechtsordnung auf den Kopf stellt. Also es heißt ja eben bei uns, dass sozusagen, solange ich nichts getan habe, der Staat mich entsprechend in Ruhe zu lassen hat. Dafür haben wir ein Grundgesetz geschaffen. Und dass es natürlich eigentlich aus der Richtung ist, eigentlich die Geschichte gelaufen, dass solange ich eben selber nichts dazu getan habe, ist der Staat sozusagen verpflichtet, sich zurückzuhalten. Deshalb ist dieser Spruch natürlich immer so für den Juristen besonders schwierig, sozusagen auszuhalten, weil es ein bisschen seine Sinngrundlage wegreißt.
Aber der Staat hat ja immer wieder Möglichkeiten, das Rechtssystem oder auch andere Elemente mal abzustrecken. Es gibt nun mal jetzt andere Möglichkeiten. Früher hatte man einen Personalbeweis oder wie auch immer und den grünen Mann auf der Straße und das reicht eben nicht mehr. Und irgendwie muss man den Bürger aber auch schützen vor sowas. Und da ist das vielleicht ein Weg, den man diskutieren kann. Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Vor was muss man den Bürger denn schützen?
Ja, es gibt ja so eine Haufenkriminalität, wir haben ja täglich damit irgendwelche Sachen konfrontiert. Teilweise auch Arztungensprinzen, aber sicherlich auch real. Und Autodiebstahl, wie auch immer, was auch immer. Und man kann sicherlich oftmals schneller eine Sache in den Griff bekommen, wenn ich diese Mittel habe, eine Fahnung zum Beispiel oder wie auch immer. Also wie gesagt, ich kann momentan keine für mich negativen Dinge erkennen.
Also der Autodiebstahl ist zumindest in den letzten Jahren ganz, ganz stark rückläufig. Hat was mit den Wegfahrsperren zu tun, die funktionieren jetzt nämlich alle.
Wenn das alles so einfach gehen würde, dann hätten wir ja gar kein Problem.
Allerdings richtig. Thomas, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und deine Argumente.
Ja, ich wünsche euch was.
0331 77 97 1 ist nur die Frage in dieser Runde. Was sind eigentlich die Vorteile von Kameraüberwachung? Hallo Nico.
Das ist nett. Ja, ich hatte jetzt gerade die Scheibenbedienung nicht da.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich war früher immer gegen Überwachung des Einzelnen in jeglicher Form. Muss aber inzwischen sagen, also an sich glaube ich, dass Kameraüberwachung die Welt schon sicherer machen könnte.
Wie kommst du denn zu diesem Sinneswandel?
Ich bin mal aus einer Videothek gekommen und da war direkt daneben ein U-Bahneingang und da bin ich die U-Bahn runtergelaufen und da waren so zwei nette Leute, die haben da Hockey gespielt. Das war 1 Uhr Nacht, es war sonst niemand mehr da und ich hab dann auch nicht mehr groß geguckt, ob die das mit Skaters gespielt haben oder nicht. Auf jeden Fall waren die Hockey-Schläger so unten so verstärkt. Und zum Teil hätte ich mir jetzt da zum Beispiel eine Playstation ausgeliehen. Die kostet ja doch einiges Geld und da hätte ich persönlich verhaften müssen, wenn die mir danach abgenommen worden wäre.
Also du hast vermutet, dass die dir mit dem Hockey-Schläger eins überziehen würden. Hättest du doch...
Nein, ich hab das jetzt einfach nur mal als allgemeines Beispiel. Also die haben nämlich nicht in dem Bereich gespielt, wo die Kameras waren. Also die Kameras waren da woanders und ich muss ehrlich sagen, mir ist bisher noch nie irgendwas passiert und dadurch haben mich Kameras noch nie geschützt. Ich fühl mich auch nicht bedroht in irgendeiner Weise. Nur ich muss sagen, dass die ganzen Daten, die von den Kameras kommen, die muss man sich ja nicht angucken. Die müssen ja gar nicht ausgewertet werden, aber für den Fall eines Verbrechens könnten sie ja ausgewertet werden.
Aber dann ist zu spät.
Es ist natürlich eine riesige Archivierung und alles, aber im Endeffekt können die Bänder doch alle zwei Tage überschrieben werden. Na ja, ich glaube schon, dass wenn bekannt ist, bis auf die Gewaltverbrechen im Effekt, werden wahrscheinlich wirklich die wenigsten Verbrecher oder die wenigsten Leute, die werden sich zweimal überlegen, wenn sie wissen, dass wir da auf dem Bild drauf sind, außer es geschieht im Effekt. Und dann fahren sie halt irgendwo in den Wald, wo es sowas nicht gibt. Aber dazu müssen sie auch erstmal an diversen Kameras vorbei, müssen die Personen erstmal einladen und alles Mögliche. Also ich glaube schon, dass Gewaltverbrechen oder generell Verbrechen leichter aufgeklärt werden können, wenn die Kameraüberwachung da ist.
Ja genau, dann müsstest du ja alles lückenlos überwachen.
Okay, okay, okay, das ist jetzt der Extremfall. Aber wie viele Leute an Geldautomaten zum Beispiel werden durch die dort aufgenommenen Bilder identifiziert? Leider viel zu wenig. Ja, das ist leider viel zu wenig.
Damit lieferst du jetzt aber gerade mit dem leider viel zu wenig, lieferst du ein Argument dafür, nicht nur die Überwachung zu verstärken, sondern auch die Biometrie einzuhalten zu lassen. Also dass am besten wir alle unsere Gesichter in einer zentralen Datenbank ablegen, damit der Geldautomaten sagen kann, wer ich war.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich meinte jetzt auch nicht dich, ich meinte Jan.
Nein, ich meinte jetzt eigentlich auch nur sozusagen, dass der 0815 Mensch, der der Oma die Karte klaut, dass der trotzdem von der, der wird von der Kamera über dem Geldautomaten nicht massiv eingeschüchtert. Aber doch, er wird trotzdem da ein bisschen dran gehindert. Kriminelle Energie kann man nie vollkommen verhindern. Die wird man auch durch Kameras nicht verhindern. Aber rein so von der, es trägt schon dazu bei, etwas sicherer zu machen. Und es ist natürlich richtig, das passt nicht ganz zu unserem Rechtssystem. Aber trotzdem hat es für jemanden, der nichts zu verbergen. Okay, ich meine klar, das stresst Kleindealer, das stresst Leute, die wirklich auch den Staaten schaden. Aber trotzdem, Kameras sind nicht cool. Und wenn ich irgendwo nachts pisse, dann freue ich mich nicht, wenn ich dabei beobachtet werde oder so was.
Das wär's, du musst noch ein Zwanziger abdrücken, weil du nachts in ein Gebüsch geschieft hast.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, ist mir auch egal. Weil wer sich das dann auf ein Bild anguckt, der wird mich darauf ja, bis er mich dann da identifiziert, müsste man jetzt aber auch wirklich, also dann werden wir wieder bei der Stasi, da bräuchten wir wieder 40 Prozent der Bevölkerung, nur dafür, dass ich die Kamera bilde.
Na, und da, die das noch können, haben wir ja noch da.
Dafür gibt's Computer demnächst.
Ja, du vergisst die Technik dabei.
Okay, na, das ist natürlich dann der interessante Aspekt, wie weit die Technik da ist.
Das wär wirklich fast alles kein Problem, wenn irgendwie nicht die Computerentwicklung so dermaßen rapide fortschreiten würde, dass man irgendwie das alles automatisch und irgendwie schnell und günstig machen könnte.
Ich meine, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, auf welcher Seite ich sein soll, auf der Seite vom Ladendieb oder auf der Seite von Karstadt. Aber trotzdem finde ich das, sozusagen, ist eigentlich, naja.
Ich hätte da eine Theorie, also gerade bei dem, aber okay. Higo, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Kein Problem, sehr gerne. Ja, wie weit sind wir denn da? Wann ist der Computer in der Lage, die gesamte Bevölkerung abzufischen? Oder innerhalb kürzester Zeit einen Abgleich zu machen mit allen Fotos, die ja ohnehin vorhanden sind, weil die meisten einen Personalausweis haben, weil sie glauben, man müsste den haben.
Da muss man jetzt erst mal, man muss den haben, das steht doch im Gesetz.
Tatsächlich? Ich muss mich doch gar nicht ausweisen können, warum brauch ich denn dann so einen Ausweis? Ich hab doch keine Ausweispflicht.
Na doch, bei einer Demo zum Beispiel.
Du hast eine Ausweispflicht.
Nein, man muss sie nicht immer dabei führen, aber wenn eben ein Anlass ist, aus Sicht des Polizisten, der dich kontrolliert, dich zu verdächtigen, dass was mit dir nicht stimmt, dann musst du den Rannkarren den ausweisen.
Echt?
Cool, dann treib ich jetzt nur auf Springerstiefel. Das ist ein großer Bahnhof.
Was mich noch interessieren würde, ist, wie ist das denn irgendwie, das ist ja auch erwähnt worden, die Sachen müssen dann ja irgendwie gesichtet werden, also wenn man, Beispiel U-Bahneingang und die bösen Hockeyspieler, wie lange wird das denn auch bewahrt? Oder wie lange kann denn die BVG dann dann nachschauen oder wann ist das denn futsch?
Ähm, so richtig rückt da die BVG auch nicht mit der Sprache raus. Also mir haben sie mal am Telefon erklärt... Mir haben sie mal erklärt am Telefon, dass es sich um eine Speicherfrist von 5 Wochen handelt, bei allen Videodaten, die auf Bahnhöfen aufgenommen werden. So, das sieht aber mitunter auch anders aus, wenn man jetzt zur Videoüberwachung in den Fahrzeugen blickt. Da haben sie halt Geräte, die das erstmal irgendwie auf die Festplatte dampen und dann ist da halt irgendwie nach einer Stunde wird das dann halt überschrieben. Aber man muss halt ganz klar sehen, das sind alles technische Grenzen und keine Grenzen, die durch irgendwelche Datenschutzrichtlinien gesetzt werden.
Na ja, rechtlich muss man ergänzen, es gibt eine Löschungsregelung und die BVG unterfällt sozusagen im Bundesdatenschutzgesetz und da steht drin, sie haben unverzüglich zu löschen. Und was bedeutet unverzüglich? Das ist also die Meisterfrage, die hier beantwortet werden muss. Jeder Betreiber beantwortet die Frage für sich selber zur Zeit und es fehlen die Kapazitäten, um da eine einheitliche Linie reinzubringen und das ist natürlich eine gewisse Willkür im Augenblick.
Warum kann der Gesetzgeber da nicht irgendwie mal ganz klare Regeln schaffen?
Das musst du dem Gesetzgeber sagen.
Weil die Politik hier in diesem Punkt hoffnungslos zerstritten ist und beim Datenschutz da teilen sich die Linken und die Rechten auf in ihre Lager.
Chaosradio 88 ist es, was ihr hört. Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten. Das Thema heute Videoüberwachung öffentlichen Raum ist 0331 70 97 110. Die Nummer, die ihr anrufen könnt und auch anrufen sollt, wenn ihr euch dazu äußern wollt, Fragen zu Videoüberwachung habt, sowohl juristischer als auch technischer Natur. Wir haben genügend Sachverstand hier im Studio versammelt und selbstverständlich auch, wenn ihr uns noch die Frage beantworten wollt. Was sind denn eigentlich die Vorteile von Videoüberwachten öffentlichen Räumen? Manfred, Bea, Flo und Thomas haben bitte ein bisschen Geduld. Wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten, danach telefonieren wir weiter.
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9.
2 nach 11.
Mit dem Wetter. In der Nacht ist es wolkig. Ich kann nicht mehr sprechen, Krischer.
Das macht nichts.
Das ist seit diesem Schlaganfall. Seit dem Schlaganfall kann ich nicht mehr richtig die Uhrzeit lesen und nicht mehr richtig sprechen. In der Nacht ist es wolkig. Es gibt einzelne Schneeschauer, die Temperaturen sinken auf minus zwei bis minus fünf Grad. Auch morgen erwarten uns immer mal wieder leichte Schneeschauer, die Höchstwerte rund um den Gefrierpunkt drum rum. Und jetzt die Meldungen mit Krischer Siedelke.
Im Brandenburg hat es im letzten Jahr offenbar mehr rechte Gewalt gegeben. Das berichtet der Tagesspiegel. Insgesamt habe die Polizei 87 Gewalttaten gezählt. Das waren sechs mehr als im Vorjahr. Die Gewaltreiche von Brandstiftungen bis hin zum versuchten Mord. Bereitschaftsdienste in Krankenhäusern zählen als Arbeitszeit. Die müssen aber nicht voll bezahlt werden. Das hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht in... Nein, das Bundesarbeitsgericht in Erfurt entschieden. Verzeihung. Die Arbeitnehmer würden in diesen Zeiten weniger beansprucht. Deshalb sei es zulässig, dass sie dann noch weniger Geld bekommen. Im Tarifstreit der Metall- und Elektroindustrie soll es ab 0 Uhr in Berlin die ersten Bahnstreiks geben. Die IG Metall hat die Nachtschicht in den Ostrahmwerken in Spandau zu Bahnstreiks aufgerufen. Morgen Vormittag sollen dann Beschäftigte von Daimler Chrysler in Marienfelde die Arbeit niederlegen. In Großbritannien gibt es nach dem Abschlussbericht zur Kelly-Affäre die ersten persönlichen Konsequenzen. Der Vorstandschef der BBC Davis hat seinen Rücktritt eingereicht. Die Untersuchung hatte ergeben, dass die BBC im Unrecht war. Sie hatte berichtet, die britische Regierung habe ein Iraktus hier aufgebrauscht. Und noch eine Meldung vom Sport. Bei der Handball-Europameisterschaft hat Deutschland gegen Gastgeber Slowenien mit 31 zu 24 gewonnen. Damit reicht den Deutschen morgen ein Unentschieden gegen Ungarn, um ins Halbfinale einzuziehen. Unter Verkehr, momentan keine Meldung, Fahrt vorsichtig. Vielen Dank, Richard.
Drei Minuten nach der Welt.
Schon wegen die Gäste, zum Beispiel Lick. Außerdem kommt er hier. Und dann gibt's da ja noch die KenFM-Solo-Ecken. Der Kollege PR Cantate. Also, Mann, Sonntag ist KenFM-Tag. Oder willst du auf dem Schulhof wieder als Loser dastehen? Ist dein Leben, Alter.
KenFM.
Die Fritz-Fritz.
Radioshow mit Ken Jepsen. Jeden Sonntag von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Chaosradio 88 auf Fritz hört hier. Kameraüberwachung, unser Thema 03317797110, die Nummer der Fritz-Otline. Wie immer sitzt der Einbeinige draußen und nimmt eure Anrufe entgegen. Stellt euch dann ins Studio, vorausgesetzt ihr habt was zu sagen, dann werdet ihr ja auch gehört. Oder vorausgesetzt ihr könnt folgende Frage beantworten. Was sind denn eigentlich die Vorteile von Videoüberwachung?
Genau und schreibt uns 88 at chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir können es hier in der Sendung jetzt auch lesen. Wir sind da nämlich ganz toll und modern. Und sobald der Computer wieder gebootet ist, dann klappt das auch. Dann können wir hier auch Sachen vorlesen. Also wenn ihr uns schreiben wollt, weil ihr nicht durchkommt oder zu faul seid zum Telefonieren, warum, 88, also 8 8, Zahlen ausgeschrieben, 88 at chaosradio.ccc.de.
Oder eben 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Hallo Manfred.
Ja, also ich ruf eigentlich aus purer Hilflosigkeit an. Weil ich weiß auch überhaupt nicht, was eine Kameraüberwachung oder irgendeinen Datenaustausch oder sowas sein soll.
Ich hab folgende Geschichte erlebt, kurz erzählt.
Nach einem Wohnungseinbruch ist ein Auto geklaut worden, der Schlüssel in der Wohnung und das Auto eben so mitgenommen.
Ging ja sehr leicht.
Und die Besitzerin des Autos bekam im folgenden Monat fünf Anzeigen wegen falsch Parkens. Der Wagen war längst abgemeldet und sie hat auch nach jeder Anzeige immer brav die Polizei angerufen und gefragt, ob man den Wagen denn nicht, weil er ja öfter auch an gleichem Ort parkte, nicht mal ausfindig machen konnte. Und da frag ich mich, ob das nicht die billigste Art und Weise ist, in Berlin Auto zu fahren, wenn man sich das einfach klaut. Man wird ja sowieso nicht erwischt.
Ja, offensichtlich. Was piept denn da? Piept das bei dir oder piept es bei uns? Das ist vielleicht mein Akku, weil ich so lange warten muss. Nee, das ist okay, weil Hauptsache es piept nicht bei uns, weil dann kommen wir wieder nicht mit der Technik klar.
Nein, aber wenn mir irgendjemand von den Experten oder so von den Leuten beantworten könnte, wenn mein Akku hier zusammengebrochen ist, in welche Art dort eigentlich überhaupt jetzt schon mal vorgegangen werden könnte innerhalb des gesamten Datenaustauschs, da wäre ich ganz dankbar.
Ich denke, das fällt unter Identitätsmissbrauch, oder? Ist das nicht so ein bisschen so wie, als wenn man den fremden Namen umherreißt und irgendwie Scheiße einstellt?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Wir müssen ja nicht überphilosophieren, was es für eine Straftat ist, ein Auto zu klauen, oder?
Das Problem, was Manfred hier hat, ist ja ganz offensichtlich, oder was seine Bekannte hat, ist, dass ein gestohlen gemeldetes, längst mit dem gestohlenen Kennzeichen abgemeldetes Auto von der Polizei immer noch als falsch geparkt registriert wird und nicht als gestohlen.
Schade.
Aber trotzdem danke für deinen Anruf, Mann. Es sieht so aus, als würde die alle was sagen wollen. Guckt mich nicht so an.
Es ist letztlich tatsächlich wieder eine datenschutzrechtliche Frage. Die Frage, ob eben hier ein Datenabgleich Behörden intern zwischen diesen Ordnungsbehördenbeamten und eben diesen kriminalpolizeilichen oder was das auch immer für Dateien sind stattfinden sollte.
Aber findet der nicht ohnehin statt?
Ja, da bin ich jetzt keine Expertin, bin ich überfragt. Aber da könnte der Manfred sich mal in den Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragten wenden und die mal fragen, wie das überhaupt genau funktioniert.
Okay, 0331 77 97 110, falls auch ihr die eine oder andere Frage oder Anekdote habt. Ich meine, das ist ja echt zu hart, oder? Klauen Sie denn Auto und dann zeigen Sie sich auch noch an die ganze Zeit. Guten Abend und herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag, BA.
Hallo.
Ich war jetzt total, ja, ich muss schon so lange warten. Ich kann noch nicht so lange reden, sonst schmeiße ich meine Mutter raus.
Wie, raus aus der Wohnung?
Nein, aus der Leitung.
Ach so, ja gut, solange du nicht ins Heim kommst, geht's ja.
Nein, ich glaube, das würde sie mir nicht antun. Na ja, okay, ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, also na ja, wie schon gesagt, wenn man nichts gemacht hat, ist es eigentlich nicht so schlimm, überwacht zu werden. Also ich frage mich dann immer, wenn man so an der Ampel steht, und dann da, also manche Ampeln sind ja schon so eine Überwachungskamera angebracht, wer guckt sich das an? Also ich stelle mir mal vor, dass irgendwo mit einer Landschaft, so ein Hochhaus mit so einer Videozentrale, wohin hatte von Werthern sich vor dem Bildschirm setzen und sich über die Leute ein ablachen. Weil, naja, wenn man so an der Ampel steht und mal so rechts und links guckt, da sind ja auch so Leute, die popeln und ja, machen noch mehr mit den Bildern.
Hast du dir mal so eine Sicherheitszentrale von einer deutschen Bahn oder so angeschaut? Oder schon allein nur in einem großen Kaufhaus? Also du kennst das schon mit diesen Monitorwänden, wo irgendwie so 20 Bilder sind, wo denn Leute sitzen mit so kleinen Joysticks, die dann mal ein bisschen ranzoomen und mal ein bisschen genauer gucken und dann sieht da mal jemand interessant aus und so? Also das passiert schon, so ist es nicht?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht. Aber andererseits vielleicht hilft es so bei Arbeitslosigkeit. Ich meine, dann brauchen sie ja ein paar Leute, die das angucken. Oder? Schon, also ich weiß nicht, sonst kann ja damit keiner was anfangen.
Wir sind also erstmal altersbezogen gefragt, du bist 15 Jahre alt. Ich unterstelle jetzt mal, dass du in einer Altersgruppe bist, in der mit Vorliebe U-Bahn Fensterscheiben zerkratzt werden. Jetzt nicht von dir, sondern von Gleichaltrigen. Denkst du, das würde die abschrecken, wenn die wüssten, dass sie jederzeit damit rechnen müssten, auf Video aufgenommen und wiedererkannt zu werden?
Nee, glaube ich eigentlich nicht, weil ich nämlich nicht glaube, dass die Bahn in der Lage ist, in fünf Wochen die auswendig zu machen. Wenn die wirklich nur fünf Wochen gelagert werden dürfen, die Videos. Also, oder wenn, dann ziehen wir sich einfach eine Mütze über oder einen Schal ein bisschen tiefer ans Gesicht und dann stört es auch keinen.
Das muss sich unser 70-jähriger Innenminister von einer 15-jährigen sagen lassen. Er hat es selber noch nicht gemerkt. Bea, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Mach's gut. Und wen haben wir denn noch? Den Thomas aus Schwirin. Hallöchen.
Ja, also ich hab das jetzt immer die ganze Zeit ein bisschen mitgehört. Sehr interessant. Meins sieht man dazu aus. Ich bin generell gegen die Überwachungsgeschichten mit der Kamera. Was ich so übel finde in diesem Land, dass die Leute das gar nicht mitkriegen, was eigentlich abgeht, und dass es irgendwie so einfach hingenommen wird, weil jeder das Gefühl hat, dass es der eigene Sicherheit dient. Was ich irgendwie so ganz nachvollziehen kann.
Das ist aber auch der Hauptgrund, genau das Gefühl. Das sind irgendwie auch die Hauptargumente von den Leuten, die das einsetzen, das Sicherheitsgefühl wird gestärkt.
Ja, aber das ist doch irgendwie... Wenn ich jetzt mal zuvor zu diesen Typen zurückkomme, der jetzt irgendwie gesagt hat, mit dieser Geschichte in der U-Bahn, ich finde das irgendwie so ein H-Mäher beigezogen. Würden die Leute einfach mal wieder so selber irgendwie ich sein und wieder sagen, wenn da jemand irgendwie Scheiße baut auf der Straße und einfach sagt, Alter, das mache ich kacke jetzt. Also so diese Zivilgarage ein bisschen mehr gesteckt werden würde, wäre das völlig hinfällig. Das Problem ist so, man denkt damit irgendwie sicherer zu sein, aber im Endeffekt wird das irgendwie in Richtung totale Kontrolle gehen und da hatte ich echt total Schiss vor.
Aber es funktioniert, es funktioniert sehr gut. Ich bin ja ein ziemlicher Spießer und ich etappe mich dabei, mich irgendwie ein bisschen besser zu fühlen, wenn ich weiß, in der U-Bahn ist eine Kamera. Das heißt, ich muss immer wieder mir auch in Erinnerungen rufen zu sagen, Moment mal, die überwachen dich gerade. Fühl ich nicht sicher. Weil also gegen den Idioten, gegen die idiotische Glatze kann ich mich wehren. Dem hau ich einfach ein paar auf die Glocken. Aber gegen eventuell irgendwelche Behörden nicht mehr.
Korrekt, gegen irgendwelche Behörden kannst du nie mehr wehren. Das ist ja der Punkt, deswegen bin ich auch total dagegen. Ich find das ziemlich schlimm, in welche Richtung das geht. Ich weiß doch nicht so, diese Überwachung am Bahnhöfen, ist das überhaupt noch öffentlicher Raum oder ist das schon wieder so halb privat von der Bahn?
Haben wir immer auch die Frage. Eigentlich dürfen sie es ja, weil es kein öffentlicher Raum ist. Da darf der Besitzer doch machen, was er will. Ich darf doch in meiner Wohnung auch eine Kamera aufstellen.
Na, das ist halt umstritten. Man kann die Bahnhöfe nicht mit der privaten Wohnung vergleichen. Ich meine, beim ÖPNV ist es sowieso erstmal so, dass sie nicht einfach nur so da sind aus Jux und Dallerei, sondern auch ganz konkrete Aufgaben haben, nämlich irgendwie Personen zu befördern. Und das ist halt relativ essenziell. Das ist sogar so essenziell, dass du halt irgendwie selbst mit dem Hausverbot bei der deutschen Bahn trotzdem irgendwie noch die Bahn benutzen können musst, wenn du halt irgendwie von A nach B möchtest.
Das heißt, ich bekomme Hausverbot nur für einen definierten Bahnhof, also nur für den Bahnhof Zoo oder wie?
Für eine bestimmte Art der Nutzung bekommst du das Hausverbot. Also für eine bestimmte Art der Nutzung, da zum Beispiel keine Zettel mehr verteilen, keine Demos mehr abhalten im Bahnhof, oder auf dem Kopf rumlaufen, sondern eben für die Nutzung der Bahn, die bleibt erhalten.
Na ja, wie wäre es also, wenn man sagt, okay, das ist ein quasi öffentlicher Raum, er ist jedem frei zugänglich, wie wäre es, wenn ich vorne an eine Schranke hinmache und nur derjenige, der eine Fahrkarte hat und auch fahren wird, kommt da rein? Wär es dann ein privater Raum?
Na ja, bei der Bahn ist es einfach schonmal deshalb anders gelagert, weil ihr Selbstverständnis von den Bahnhöfen einfach viel weiter reicht. Es ist halt nicht nur, da steigt man ein und da steigt man aus, sondern da sollst du halt auch hingehen, um jetzt meinetwegen den Wochenendeinkauf zu machen.
Zum Beispiel am Bielefelder Bahnhof, hast du den mal gesehen?
Ich war da noch nicht.
Den Bahnhof schon. Irgendwie müssen sie es uns ja auch.
Aber nicht in Bielefeld.
Ich finde der Thomas hat einen ganz wichtigen Punkt gehabt, mit dieser Delegation von Verantwortung sozusagen an die Kameras. Das finde ich wirklich einen spannenden Punkt, den man auch mal untersuchen müsste. Ob nicht einfach durch diese Kamera- Struktur, Infrastruktur, die da jetzt wächst, vielleicht auch bei einer ganzen Reihe von Leuten der Eindruck entsteht, sie könnten jetzt ihren Einsatz, ihre Zivilcourage einfach an diese Dinge delegieren und müssten selber da nicht mehr im öffentlichen Raum irgendwie verantwortlich handeln.
Machen die Leute das überhaupt noch? Das ist mal in den Raum gestellt.
Zum Beispiel dieses Problem, was ich so mal reingeworfen hab, das fällt mir gerade in Deutschland, auch in den Staaten irgendwie auf. Es gibt ja auch Länder, die ganz anders rangehen. Ob das nur Kanada ist oder sonst die, wo die Leute nicht mal die Türen abschließen. Wo das auch überhaupt kein Thema ist, wo auch nichts passiert. Erstaunlicher ist aber gerade in den Staaten, wo halt dieser Druck ist und auch die Leute mit dieser latenten Art überwacht zu werden und das auch irgendwie so hinnehmen und so weiter, wo das irgendwie alles so in die Richtung geht, passieren aber wesentlich mehr Sachen. Also es hat ja wirklich nichts mit Sicherheit zu tun.
Videoüberwachung ist halt auch so ein städtisches Phänomen. Also ich glaube, ich kenne keine Dörfer, wo irgendwie amtlich viele Videokameras installiert sind. So, weil im Dorf funktioniert das mit der Selbstkontrolle. Da kennt jeder jeden. Und wenn da halt irgendwie die Glatzen einreiten und irgendwie auf die Kacke schlagen, dann weiß das nicht.
Das ist groß geworden. Ich kann dir erklären, was wir mit den Kameras gemacht hätten, wenn wir die gefunden hätten, wenn wir klein waren.
Ja, aber gut, ich meine, das sollte wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal an der ampelanlagen vielleicht eine Kamera dran sein.
Das wird in Zukunft passieren, auf jeden Fall. Also hat ja die Innenministerkonferenz zumindest so nicht beschlossen, aber zumindest schon mal diskutiert.
Also ich finde das total abartig. Ich weiß nicht, also ich, die ganze Entwicklung dahingehend, also tut mir leid, ich fahre auch mal nachts gerne super schnell. Und dieser Gedanke daran, dass ich echt an jeder Ecke aufpassen muss, dass ich mich auch ja an den gesetzlichen Rahmen bewege und alles so mache, wie ich es halt, das Gesetz möchte. Ich meine, was ist da überhaupt noch das Leben?
Also sorry, aber damit musst du leben. Wenn dir die Regeln nicht passen, die wir haben, dann musst du versuchen, sie zu ändern, aber sie nicht einfach zu brechen. Na komm, also auf einer prinzipiellen Ebene natürlich.
Also stell dir mal vor, du würdest so leben, also wirklich so, so wie ich es wirklich vorgeschrieben habe. Also ich meine, so richtig gesetzestreu, so richtig so. Also ich meine, denk doch mal so an die letzte Woche zurück. Vielleicht schon mal so ein CD kopiert oder so.
Das Problem ist, ich fahre nicht so schnell. Nicht mehr.
Es gibt einen Soziologen, der dazu was Interessantes geschrieben hat, der sagte, wenn es tatsächlich, man müsste sich vorstellen, wenn tatsächlich alle Straftaten aufgedeckt werden könnten. Also wenn man das nur mal überlegt, dann würde diese Gesellschaft zusammenbrechen. Der Justizapparat als erstes, anschließend alle sozialen, persönlichen Beziehungen, die wir untereinander haben, weil wir Sachen von anderen erfahren, die wir nicht wissen wollen und so weiter und so weiter.
Der Satz, den er gesagt hat, ist, wenn jeder das bekäme, was er verdiente, dann würde die Gesellschaft zusammenbrechen. Thomas, erstmal danke für deinen Anruf und schönes Schwerin noch.
Bitte schön, tschüss.
Guck mal nach Bremen. In Bremen wird schon überwacht.
Ja, also hier gibt es momentan seitens der BSAG, das ist hier die lokale Betreibergesellschaft der Straßenbahnen und Busse. Bestrebungen eben diese zu überwachen in einigen Straßenbahnen, ist das bereits Realität. Und in einer solchen wurde ein Überfall verübt. Diese Straßenbahnen wurden überfallen. Und diese Bilder haben eben, oder diese Kameras haben eben weder abgeschreckt, noch haben sie zur Aufklärung dieser Tat beigetragen.
Das heißt, das Opfer und den Täter?
Und da weiß ich schon, wo das Ding führen soll.
Also der Täter läuft noch frei rum?
Wann ist das ungefähr passiert?
Bitte?
Jetzt würde mich ja dann mal die Frage interessieren, kann ich denn dann nicht die Verkehrsbetriebe verklagen? Ich mein, immerhin suggerieren, die sagen, fahr mit uns, hier ist es sicher. Und selbst wenn du aufs Maul kriegst, werden wir den Bösewicht schon finden. Kann ich da nicht hingehen und sagen, hör mal zu, ihr Arschlöcher?
Also ich hatte vor zwei Tagen eben den Fall, dass da ein sehr stark angetrunkener Herr, ich sag mal um die 50 rum, eben durch die Bahn torkelte und jeden anquatschte.
Also ich hab ihn nicht verstanden.
Und ich hab mich in dem Moment halt schon ein bisschen bedroht gefühlt. Eben auch weil mir nicht ganz klar war, worauf der hinaus wollte. Und ich glaub auch den anderen ging das so. Aber sicher hab ich mich nicht gefühlt. Obwohl eben gerade diese Bahn, das war die erste Bahn, in der mir das überhaupt auffiel, videoüberwacht war.
Da waren wirklich diese Schilder dran.
Achtung, Videoüberwacht.
Und man hat auch diese schwarzen Halbkugeln an der Decke gesehen.
Aber sicher hab ich mich dadurch nicht gefühlt.
Wie ist denn das, Nils? Hab ich einen Rechtsanspruch auf Sicherheit? Wenn die Kameras einbauen und sagen, das machen wir für die Sicherheit, hab ich dann irgendeinen Anspruch darauf, dass es sicher ist?
Also noch ein Verständnis nicht.
Da kam keine Durchsage seitens des Straßenbahnfahrers, wir leiden das jetzt mal weiter oder so. Also nichts, was einen irgendwie beruhigt hätte.
Also man kann das schon mal ganz pragmatisch sich vorstellen, dass die Bahn in keinerlei Weise eine Garantie geben möchte für ihre Kunden, weil sie das versicherungstechnisch niemals einlösen könnte, die möglichen Ansprüche, die auf sie zukommen. Also man kann sich schon so ganz pragmatisch überlegen, dass das nicht hinhaut. Aber die Frage ist natürlich in Zukunft, wenn mit der Videoüberwachung so offensiv geworben wird und mit der Sicherheit, die angeblich damit verbunden sei, ob nicht dann irgendwann tatsächlich mal ein Kunde hingehen kann und sagen kann, ich hab hier eine Garantenpflicht für meine Sicherheit und mir ist das und das passiert und jetzt zahlt dafür. Das ist vielleicht in Zukunft irgendwann mal denkbar. Im Augenblick würde ich sagen, ist das rechtlich nicht haltbar.
Was müsste passieren, damit es rechtlich haltbar wird? Also andersherum gefragt, wann gehen wir beide hin und führen einen Musterprozess?
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich eine sehr spezielle Frage. Man muss erst mal unterscheiden, ob das nachher ein Haftungsprozess um Schadensersatz ist oder geht es um einen Strafprozess, weil mir jemand auf die Nase gekloppt hat und ich will wegen unterlassener Hilfeleistung vorgehen gegen die Bahn. Da muss man sehr genau im Detail schauen, um welchen Fall handelt es sich.
Tschüss.
Eine Minute Musik, danach telefonieren wir weiter. Chaosradio 88 hier auf Fritz heute mit der Kamerabewachung öffentlicher Räume und euren Anrufen, Anmerkungen und Fragen unter 0331 70 97 110 und fürchterlich lange in der Leitung hängt schon Flo aus dem Prenzlauer Berg. Eine Frage hast du.
Ja, also ich hab mal so Gerüchte über die Londoner U-Bahn gehört, die ist ja nun komplett videoüberwacht, da hängt ja an jeder Ecke, an jeder Rolltreppe, irgendwie teilweise in den U-Bahn-Zügen Kameras, dass die wirklich drauf und dran sind, also schon das war vor ein, zwei Jahren oder so, dass die dabei sind, ein Tracking-System hochzuziehen, dass die Kamera zum einen Gesichtserkennung macht und versucht, Leute, die da vorbeirennen, gegen eine Datei mit gesuchten Leuten, irgendwie eine Fahndungsdatei laufen zu lassen. Und zum anderen das Feature, dass man Personen markieren kann und das System einem dann die Personen trackt und nachverfolgen kann, irgendwie wo man langgeht und dir sagen kann, irgendwie diese Person war vor zwei Stunden da und da.
Markieren mit so Gottscher-Waffen, ne? So was in der Art.
Also ein Tracking, dass man eine Person anklicken kann und dann gibt es einen grünen Kringel um den Kopf und dann wird er halt getrackt, egal ob er umsteigt und egal ob er an eine andere Station fährt oder sonst. Er wird halt einfach getrackt und das ist möglich angeblich. Auf grundhäutiger Technik. Und ich würde gern wissen, ob ihr irgendwelche Infos habt und mir sagen könnt, was an diesen Gerüchten dran ist und wie weit die Technik prinzipiell ist, ob das technisch möglich ist, beziehungsweise ob man weiß, ob sowas möglich ist.
Also erste Frage, Gesichtserkennung funktioniert noch nicht. Also es gibt bis jetzt kein wirklich im Einsatz befindliches System, was ausreichend gute Matching-Ergebnisse liefert, dass man irgendwie sagen kann, wir haben hier die große Datenbank und du sag mir jetzt mal, wer da gerade lang gelaufen ist. Zweite Frage, funktioniert. Also irgendwie du kannst, es gibt Software, die gibst du kaufen, kannst du irgendwie installieren und einen Videostream reinladen und dann klickst du irgendwie Gesicht an und die Kamera verfolgt dann automatisch das Gesicht. Also es ist nicht nur mit Leuten verfolgen, sondern explizit auch auffälliges Verhalten. Also zum Beispiel wenn du jetzt unvermittelt losrennst, können sie irgendwie das automatisch dediktieren oder wenn da auch wie ein Koffer über 5 Stunden lang im Bahnhof steht, können sie es auch dediktieren und dann geht halt die große rote Warnleuchte an und sagt Miep Miep Miep und da läuft da was schief.
Gut, dann hab ich zum Beispiel auch so eine Urban Legend gehört, dass zum Beispiel in London Alkoholausschränklizenzen an Pubs und so was nur vergeben werden, wenn die Lokalitäten videoüberwacht sind.
Dann wird mitgezählt.
Genau, Peinz zählen, das ist das Finanzamt, das das fordert. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
War sogar auf dem Kongress, also hat irgendwie ein Gast aus London auf dem Kongress mal erzählt.
Wann war denn das? Vor zwei Jahren schon, echt. Kann ich mir, also wüsste ich nicht. Es gibt irgendwie die Sache mit den RFID-Tags in den Biergläsern, die dann automatisch schreien, wenn das Glas leer ist. Aber im Video hatten wir so, also die Geschichte kenn ich nicht.
Entschuldigung, wie merkt der Tag, wie merkt er das?
Na...
Druck, Temperatur, was wird er so, kennt er noch nicht?
Na, das ist halt ein extra Sensor dran. Oder vielleicht irgendwie auch so, dass du das Glas an der Ecke in die Mitte vom Tisch stellst, irgendwie auf den Laser rauf und hast nicht mehr hier Kellner, komm her, sondern irgendwie automatisch gleich.
In Köln geht es eher automatisch, übrigens hier so lange Bier bis du umfällst.
Naja, und jetzt hab ich eigentlich auch noch einen Vorteil, ich weiß nämlich was der Vorteil von Kameraüberwachung ist. Ja, man kann sich's hinterher anschauen.
Kannst du das?
Naja, dafür hat man doch die Kameras, dass man hinterher ein Video hat, wo man sagen kann, hier sind die Attentäter, die das Flugzeug in die Luft gesprengt haben, gerade durch die Passkontrolle gegangen.
So sahen wir aus.
Ich meine, das ist doch der Vorteil, oder? Sondern einen anderen hat man nicht.
Hast du mal einen Vorteil? Willst du Innenminister werden?
Nö, ich finde, also ich meine, das ist aber das einzigste, was einem einfällt, was ein Vorteil sein kann. Die Nachteile dagegen sind erheblich.
Innenminister kann man übrigens nicht werden, wenn man solcherlei Gedanken schon vorher hat. Innenminister entwickeln solcherlei Gedanken immer erst hinterher.
Ja, ich will auch nicht Innenminister werden, danke.
Du kannst dich auch nicht mehr. Ja, aber wie gesagt, Politiker sind ja dazu da immer erst, nachdem das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen ist, irgendwas zu tun.
Hat bestimmt auch noch ganz andere Gedanken im Hintergrund.
Wer jetzt? Ach so, ich dachte Innenminister.
Ein Link hätte ich noch.
Deswegen sind Köpfe ja auch rund.
Ein Link!
Ein Paper, was sich damit beschäftigt, wie man versteckte Kameras sendet.
Ja, hast du, du hast ja sicherlich Internets bei dir zu Hause, richtig? Ja, guck mal, mach doch mal. Ja, nicht nur das, du kannst es auch viel haben, also so ein Board nennt sich das, www.fritz.edu.
Ja, das hab ich gerade probiert.
88erchaosradio.ccc.com Mit dem V-Chat zumindest.
Nein, nicht mit dem V-Chat, sondern einfach aufs Board eintragen. Also quasi wie ein Forum. Schreib da den Link mal hin, dann können es nämlich wirklich alle gucken. Mails trotz dem noch mal.
Genau, bitte mailen.
Eine Mail kann ich auch schicken.
Wunderbar.
Ja, dann kommt es auch noch mal bei uns an. Vielen Dank Flo. So, oh, in Panko, was denn?
Ich hab ne ganz Menge, ihr schreibt wie wahnsinnig. Das ist toll.
Ja, schön. Hör mal, ohne Ende Anrufer. Dazu ist die Sendung ja auch da. Matthias aus Panko. Du arbeitest bei der BVG. Sehr schön.
Erzähl mal die direkten Details bitte. Die schmutzigen Details bitte.
Bei der Straßenbahn arbeitest du.
Ja, und da haben wir, wir haben ein paar Fahrzeuge Video überwacht. Und da lassen die Zerstörung präventiv, also das hilft präventiv absolut, da lassen die Zerstörung total nach.
Ist das wirklich so? Wie ist das genau? Also ich hatte mal in einer Zeitung gelesen gehabt, dass das System in den Straßenbahnen so funktioniert, dass halt zum Ende einer Fahrt der Fahrer durch die Waggons stiefelt und dann einfach guckt, ob irgendwie zwischen den Kratzern neue entstanden sind und dann irgendwie auf den Knopf drückt, der dann sozusagen die aktuellen Viewdaten wegspeichert.
Die Frage, die Martin gerade versucht zu stellen, ist ganz einfach, wie funktioniert es technisch mit der Überwachung und was hast du dabei zu tun?
Also ich hab dabei nicht so viel zu tun, weil ich nicht Straßenmann fahre, sondern mehr für die Wartung und Pflege zuständig bin. Aber so ähnlich funktioniert es. Du wirst das bei keiner Fall Gongs haben, sondern Fahrgasträume.
Kannst du vielleicht ein bisschen was dazu sagen, wie das bei der U-Bahn funktioniert? Hast du dir ein bisschen Einblick, wie das mit dem DMB und so aussieht?
Nee, da hab ich leider überhaupt keinen Einfluss und keinen Einsicht drin. Ich kann nur sagen, wie gesagt, dass ich die Videoüberwachung, dass die ungefertigt ist, weil die Daten an sich überhaupt nicht überwacht werden.
Aber ist sie denn nicht sinnlos?
Sie kann nicht speichert werden.
Kann?
Sie kann.
Auf wessen Ansage ihnen passiert das?
Wenn der Fahrer zum Beispiel selbst weiß, dass was passiert ist. Ansonsten fällt es runter, wie auf dem Fließband. Dann wird überschrieben. Kann eigentlich keiner was mit anfangen, aber für diejenigen, die eben dann was getan haben, die können im Nachhinein festgestellt werden.
Wenn sie erkannt werden von dem System?
Na sicherlich, wenn sie erkannt werden. Aber dafür kann man natürlich keine Garantien geben, dass sie erkannt werden. Ich meine, ich hab da heute als Thema gehabt, dass man da Garantien geben kann. Genauso, wo der einer angerufen hat, dass wir den Potsdamer und Verkehrsbetrieben, dass da wohl, wenn ein besoffener durchgeht, der Fahrer gleich was machen müsste. Dafür gibt es Möglichkeiten, den Fahrer zu kontaktieren.
Außer bei der S-Bahn?
Na gut, bei der S-Bahn weiß ich nicht. Das ist eben die Deutsche Bahn.
Zeitweise außer Betrieb.
Sämtliche Sprechgeräte sind immer außer Betrieb.
Aber wie ist denn das? Ist das nicht möglicherweise so, dass mit den neuen Fahrzeugen bei der Straßenbahn einfach dadurch, dass die schicker, moderner sind, dass die Leute da vielleicht mehr Respekt haben, dass es deswegen zurückgeht?
Wir hatten die neuen Straßenbahn ja an einsseits ohne Kameras. Und ich hab auch meiner Frau solche auf Kleber mal mitgegeben. Die hat so bei sich ran gemacht auf Arbeit, weil Jugendliche immer wieder ran gemalt haben.
Wo jetzt auf Arbeit? Die fährt Straßenbahn oder was?
Nein, die ist woanders tätig. Die hat die angeklebt da und hat sich bei Konrad so eine Kamera besorgt, die einfach nur mitschwenkt. Ja, automatisch, also diese Bewegungssensoren sind da drin. Aber die filmt nicht, die hat einfach so einen Adapter. Vielleicht so eine Art Trappe. Und seitdem hört das auch auf. Du musst heutzutage nicht mehr überwachen. Du musst nur sagen, hier wird überwacht.
Überwachungsandrohung.
Aber glaubst du denn, dass die Jugendlichen weniger irgendwelche Sachen beschmieren oder weniger kaputt machen? Ja, nur die Frage ist, ob sie woanders hingehen.
Ich glaube, die Mitläufer kriegst du damit.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie es deswegen sein lassen. Ich denke nur, dass sie woanders hingehen.
Dann können sie es doch machen.
Solange es nicht meine Straßenbahn ist klar.
Nein, das sind erhebliche Kosten. Eine Scheibe, wenn sie ausgetauscht werden muss, kostet nicht nur das Material, sondern auch die Arbeitskraft. Ich meine, Geld, Gelder und alle Klammen.
Okay, aber dann muss die Straßenbahn Haltestelle dran hier halten.
Nein, da muss auch Überwachung werden. Immer da, wo Straftaten häufiger werden, wird es dazu führen, dass da Videoüberwachung ist. Aber sie ist ja so schlecht nicht. Sie ist natürlich dann schlecht, wenn sie ständig überwacht wird von irgendwelchen Leuten. Aber wenn man im Nachhinein, wenn die Kamera einfach nur läuft, ohne dass irgendwer da drin guckt, ohne dass biometrische Programme da ablaufen und so weiter, das habe ich eigentlich nicht dagegen. Schlimm wird es dann, wenn man schon denkt, hier wird gleich ein Straftat passieren, hier werden wir mal alle zugucken, wenn die Intimsführer im Prinzip verletzt wird.
Moment, du hast doch gerade gesagt, wir sind alle klamm. Glaubst du denn, dass die Kameras für lau rausgehauen werden? Die kosten ja auch Geld.
Und zwar nicht zu knapp?
Na, ich glaube, pro Wagen rechnet die BVG mit irgendwie 12.000 Euro oder so.
Da kannst du schon ein paar Scheiben für austauschen.
Keine Ahnung, was kosten die Scheiben?
Genau, was kosten die Scheiben? Die kosten mich richtig Geld und die Arbeitskraft kostet auch richtig Geld.
Weißt du, was es kostet, eine Scheibe auszutauschen?
Wie auch immer, aber wie gesagt, was ich sagen will, ist, du löst ja das Problem damit nicht. Du verdrängst es ja nur, das Problem der Sachbeschädigung.
Nicht mal verdrängen. Gut, aber auch die videoüberwachten Straßenbahnen, irgendwie Linie 20, haben zerkratzte Scheiben.
Selbstverständlich haben sie die. Weil es ja einfach nicht so einzuschrecken geht, dass man, selbst wenn man es wollte, kommt man ja nicht hinterher, wie er es schon festgestellt hat. Man schafft es ja nicht, ständig alle Daten auszulesen, ständig alle zu machen und alle zu überprüfen. So viele Zeit hat ja kein Mensch. Das würde ja mehr kosten, als die Schäden nur zu beseitigen.
Aber was glaubst du denn, wie lange das dauert, bis sich das rumgesprochen hat, dass sich das ja eh alles niemand anguckt, dass es ja eh nicht so viel bringt mit den Kameras?
Das ist ja kein Problem. Weil? Das ist ja überschaubar. Die Anzahl der Kameras, der Fahrer geht relativ zeitnah durch den Wagen. Ja, und kann das alles feststellen, aber wenn ich mir vorstelle...
Aber dann ist die Scheibe schon zerkratzt.
Ja, okay, na gut.
Hast du doppelte Kosten.
Ja, Kamera und Scheibe.
Ja, aber dann stellt er halt fest und kann dem nachgegangen werden.
Kann er es denn wirklich feststellen, ob neben den Dreikratzer noch ein Vierter dazugekommen ist?
Okay, und dann wird geguckt, da ist halt ein Typ vielleicht 15 mit Kapuze...
Dann gucken diejenigen, die dafür zugelassen sind, oder vielmehr die Personen, die dafür datenrechtlich das machen dürfen, sind ja ganz wenige Ausnahmen, die das machen dürfen, gucken sich dann den 24-Stunden-Tag beziehungsweise in Stufen an, wann noch nichts war, und wann dann was offensichtlich ist. Kann man ja relativ schnell einschränken, die Zeit. Und schon weiß man ungefähr, wer das war. Und der ist ja dann rückverfolgt.
Naja, frage mal an unseren Juristen. Dürfen die, also angenommen, ich hätte ein wunderbar klares Standbild von jemandem, der diese Scheibe zerkratzt, oder den Sitz beschmiert oder sonst irgendwie was macht, dürfte ich dieses Foto in der Zeitung veröffentlichen und sagen, wer war das?
Die Polizei darf das offensichtlich, ja?
Na, ich weiß es nicht.
Also in der Zeitung erstmal nicht. Das wäre eine Verbreitung des Bildes, die grundsätzlich eigentlich der Einwilligung des Betroffenen unterliegt. Es sei denn jetzt, die Polizei würde das im Rahmen einer Fahndung rausgeben.
Da würde die Bildzeitung.
Naja, aber zum ersten Mal. Die Fotos vom Banküberfall, die rausgegeben werden, das ist dann im Rahmen einer Fahndung. Das heißt, würde ich das Beschmieren von Scheiben kriminalisieren, also tatsächlich einen Straftatbestand draus machen, falls es noch keiner ist. Ich weiß es nicht. Dann könnte im Rahmen einer Fahndung dieses Foto von demjenigen, der die Scheibe beschmiert, veröffentlicht werden.
Ja, wenn es darum geht, den zu identifizieren, das haben wir auch bei den Krawallen am 1.
Mai.
Da haben wir auch sozusagen die Kapuzenleute, die sie da vermeintlich als Sachbeschädiger entdeckt haben, dass die eben auch mit Bild in der Zeitung erscheinen. Das ist schon möglich.
Ich hoffe, das hört jetzt keiner vom Gesetzgeber. Sonst haben wir bald die Zeitung voll davon. Nehmen wir mal auf Milchtüten, wär doch schön.
Was auch zum Beispiel sehr gut ist, ist der Schutz der Kollegen, die Straßenbahn fahren.
Also ich hab noch nie von einem Straßenbahnfahrer gehört, der von Glatzen verprügelt wurde. Das sind meistens nur irgendwelche Ausländer. Echt?
Krass. Ja, da hab ich ihm einfach nur darum gebeten, dass er seine Frisalien doch bitte draußen lassen soll. Die er da rund triefend und...
Hat wieder einer Fondue gemacht.
Und das hat ihm eben nicht gefallen.
Aber reicht da nicht irgendwie das Funksystem aus? Also man könnte doch in so einem Fall auch über Betriebsfunk die Polizei herbeirufen. Dafür muss man ja nicht...
Natürlich, die Glatze wartet. Die steht dann da und sagt, na wann kommen sie denn? Ich warte noch so lange. Nee, nee, ist nicht so. Es geht ja darum, um die Feststellung der Person, die es war. Es geht ja danach als Hilfe, würde der verwendet, diese Videoaufnahme.
Ja gut, aber die Leute tragen ja nicht irgendwie groß ihren Namen und ihre Personalausweisnummer auf dem T-Shirt.
Doch, die heißen alle Lonsdale.
Nee, aber es ist ja eine Affekthandlung, wenn einer einen Fahrer bedroht, zum Beispiel. Da steht ja nicht, macht ja kein normaler Mensch. Der Mensch muss also...
Ja, aber wie oft kommt denn das vor?
Ich sag mal, das war so zu ehenswermer monatelang schon.
Ja, aber es ist doch wieder die Frage, was hast du davon, dass es aufgezeichnet wurde? Du hast dann das blaue Auge, und den anderen kriegen sie wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie ihn kriegen, ist zumindest erhöht, von dem Fall, dass dieser jemand schon mal irgendwo auffällig geworden ist.
Also ich denke immer auch, der steigt in den Straßenbahn ein und weiß noch nicht, dass er jetzt gleich den Fahrer in die Haut.
Ja gut, aber da sind wir jetzt auch irgendwie bei diesem Minority Report Fall, dass wir einfach, wenn wir überall diese Kameras jetzt aufstellen und jeder Private zum Beispiel eben dafür sorgt, dass bei ihm nichts zerkratzt wird und er da Kameras aufhängt und sozusagen jeder für seine Scholle dafür sorgt, dass da eine Kamera hängt, dann sind wir eben flächendeckend irgendwann versorgt und jagen eben diesem Traum nach sozusagen jeden Straftäter sofort stellen zu können und dieses Problem lösen zu können. Ich halte das für eine Utopie und sag mal also was altmodisches, ganz altmodisches, es geht nicht nur darum, dass hier eine Sachbeschädigung sozusagen im Raum steht, sondern es geht auch darum, dass natürlich permanent die Grundrechte der Kunden der BVG betroffen sind. Das wird die BVG sicher auch nicht bestreiten. Und das da dann natürlich eine angemessene Ausgleich sozusagen zwischen diesen Freiheitsrechten und dem Sicherheitsanspruch der BVG gefunden werden muss.
Nö, das finde ich nicht, weil welche Persönlichkeitsrechte sind denn bei Einfluss von der Mütterstraße?
Das ist in dem Moment, wo du natürlich von der Videokamera erfasst wirst, sind deine Grundrechte, dein Persönlichkeitsrecht betroffen.
Dann ist ja deine Persönlichkeitsrechte nicht auch schon betroffen, wenn ich dich einfach nur angucke über den Spiegel.
Nee, das ist nicht dasselbe, weil die Videokamera natürlich eine technische Anlage ist und dadurch andere Möglichkeiten da sind. Damit kannst du natürlich die Daten speichern, du kannst diese Daten verarbeiten.
Okay, okay, ich kann aber auch dein wieder in die Sicht merken und manche haben Fotografische, die der Echt ist, die können sich da dann vielleicht ja einen Steckbrief rausbringen, so eine Zeichnung machen.
Ja, und hätte unser Hund nicht, dann hätte er, also funktioniert es eben nicht. Aber das wird ja nicht gespeichert. Natürlich wird es gespeichert, sobald der Fahrer auf den Knopf drückt.
Sobald der Fahrer auf den Knopf drückt, dafür muss ein Hund gehen.
Schlimmer noch, und dann bin ich auf dem Video, obwohl ich überhaupt nichts mit dieser ganzen Sache zu tun hab. Was hab ich da zu suchen auf dem Video?
Ja, bist du ja nicht, weil du nicht weißt, wie die Zeit gespeichert wird.
Nur wenn du dabei warst.
Ja, wenn ich genau zu der Zeit da gesessen hab.
Hinter mir sitzt jemand, der irgendwie eine Scheibe zerkratzt.
Du bist ja doch ein Zeuge.
Wenn ich gerade Zeitung gelesen habe, bin ich kein Zeuge.
Vielleicht hast du ja viel mehr Sachen gesehen, als die jemals speichern könnten.
Wenn ich gerade Zeitung gelesen hab, bin ich kein Zeuge. Ich bin aber trotzdem auf dem Video drauf. Und für den Fall, dass mir gerade kalt ist und ich noch eine Kapuze anhabe, unterstellt mir irgendein irre gewordener Staatsanwalt. Ich hätte gegen das Vermummungsverbot verstoßen und würde noch wesentlich Schlimmeres im Schilde führen.
Ich werde dann auch noch die Zeitungsanzeige gesucht.
Natürlich sind das Horrorszenarien. Aber das Horrorszenario, was wir seit Jahren immer wieder erzählen, ist von ein paar Monaten zum Beispiel mal eingetreten. Es ist einer Frau, die Einreise in die Vereinigten Staaten verweigert worden, weil ihre Wunschliste bei Amazon.de Bücher ausgewiesen hat, die der Einwanderungsbehörde nicht gefallen hat.
Aber wer will denn in die USA?
Das ist jetzt natürlich eine ganz andere Frage.
Ich würde das über die Brasilianer machen. Ich würde das genauso machen. Ich würde jedem Amerikaner hier die gleichen Schikanen zukommen lassen, wie die Ausländer in Amerika.
Die sind doch schon gestraft genug dadurch, dass sie häufig genug merken müssen, dass wir hier mehr über ihr eigenes Land wissen als sie selber. Matthias, ich danke für deinen Anruf. Mittlerweile 13 Minuten nach 23 Uhr, Chaosradio 88, Blue Moon. Und es geht um Kameraüberwachung, wir bitten um ein bisschen Geduld von Andreas, Philipp, Jörg und Boris, wir müssen sie jetzt erstmal ein paar Minuten zurücklehnen. Chaosradio 88, Kameraüberwachung vom öffentlichen Raum, unter anderem unser Thema heute Abend. Und angerufen hat Andreas aus Meerbusch, das ist in der Nähe von Düsseldorf.
Hallo.
In der Nähe von Neuss.
Zu der Technik von Kameraüberwachung, ich hab mir da zwar eigentlich noch nie groß Gedanken drüber gemacht oder mich damit beschäftigt oder so, aber ich war mal irgendwann vor etlichen Jahren in irgendeinem Museum in, ich glaub, das war in München, irgendwie so ein technisches Museum, ich weiß aber nicht mehr wie das hieß.
Deutsches Museum?
Und da gab es irgendwie so ein, ich weiß gar nicht genau was das war, das war eine Kamera mit irgendeinem Computer dran, wo man sich dann selber auf dem Monitor sehen konnte und dann wurden dann immer da, wo der Kopf ist, wurde dann irgendwie so ein Kreis eingeblendet. Das war zwar nicht besonders beeindruckend, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie zehn Jahre her, das Ding war damals irgendwie schon gnadenlos verheiltet, also dass da irgendwie kein C4 drin war war auch schon alles. Und ich weiß nicht, wenn das damals schon ging, dann glaube ich eigentlich schon, dass heutzutage.
Na ist das, was wir vorhin hatten, halt irgendwie automatische, also Gesichterverfolgung, also nicht Erkennung, sondern, dass er sagt, da ist das Gesicht und das läuft jetzt irgendwie da durchs Bild durch.
Aber hieß das nicht, dass wenn ich einmal dicke Backen mache, das Ding denkt, ah nee, das ist er nicht, dann muss ich weiter suchen?
Nee, es guckt ja nicht irgendwie dein Gesicht, sondern irgendwie es hat einmal das Gesicht und verfolgt dann halt nur noch diesen orangen Fleck durchs Bild.
Gut, aber das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht sagen. Ich wollte eigentlich anrufen, weil die Anrufe, die bis jetzt kamen, haben eigentlich schon gezeigt, dass den Leuten es scheinbar völlig egal ist, was irgendwie passiert. Und es nicht nur egal ist, sondern es wird den Leuten regelrecht schmackhaft gemacht. Von wegen, dass Überwachung ja eine Sache ist, womit man natürlich nur Verbrecher fängt und nur Terroristen und nur...
Genau, der internationale Terrorismus, der wird dann immer zur Not rangezogen, wenn irgendwie gerade mal keine Graffiti Sprayer an dir sind.
Wenn der sich gerade ruhig verhält, dann sind sie Nazis, der Aufstand der anständigen Kameraleute.
Und Kinderporno.
Wenn dann mal wieder so ein Nazi-Terror-Kinderporno-Raubkopierer-Ring aufgezogen ist, wird das auch ganz gut aus in der Zeitung. Und irgendwie auch dieses... Die Leute haben irgendwie den Eindruck, es nimmt ihnen ja niemand was weg, wenn sie gefilmt werden, weil das Gesicht von denen ist ja immer noch an der dafür vorgesehenen Stelle.
Das wär geil, so ein Matrix-Ding, so ein Matrix-Effekt.
Und dann die Leute, man kommt gar nicht auf die Idee, dass einem da irgendwie wirklich was weggenommen wird. Nämlich irgendwie die Freiheit, irgendwo hinzugehen, ohne überall ständig gefilmt und beobachtet zu werden.
Aber ich höre raus, dass es bei dir ein bisschen anders ist. Ist es so, dass du das eher kritisch siehst? Hör ich das richtig raus? Diskutierst du mit Freunden, mit Bekannten auch mal über so ein Thema? Kommt das vor?
Ja, allerdings, da ist es dann meistens so, dass, also ich stell eigentlich immer wieder fest, dass die Leute sich da entweder gar keine Gedanken drum machen, also da irgendwie noch nie großartig drüber nachgedacht haben. Weil man kriegt ja auch nicht mit. Das ist ja nicht wie in der DDR oder wie, also wir haben auch nicht 1984, sondern wir sind inzwischen schon 20 Jahre weiter. Das Ganze ist also ein bisschen versteckter und ein bisschen subtiler und wird einem eher noch schmackhaft gemacht, als dass jetzt irgendwie richtig mit Gewalt hier das durchgesetzt wird.
Dieses Verhältnis verschiebt sich da halt auch irgendwie. Während es früher meinetwegen so war, dass auf dem Marktplatz irgendwie der Dorfpolizist stand und jeder den Polizisten sehen konnte und irgendwie der Polizist die anderen weitestgehend, verschiebt sich halt dieses Verhältnis von, was weiß der Überwachte und welche Möglichkeiten haben die Bewacher. Das wurde halt auch gerne als das panoptische Prinzip bezeichnet, dass halt irgendwie gerade derjenige, der überwacht wird, immer weniger über das ganze Vorgehen mitbekommt. Da gibt es halt irgendwie verschiedene Qualitäten auch bei der Videoüberwachung. Zum Beispiel sind das irgendwie Speicherung oder Vernetzung, also technische Vernetzung oder irgendwie Kompetenzüberschneidung, wo meinetwegen der private Sicherheitsdienst bei der Bahn irgendwie Tür an Tür sitzt mit dem Bundesgrenzschutz, die halt alle irgendwie verschiedene Kompetenzen haben und sich das halt irgendwie überlagert.
Aber die gleiche Technik benutzen letztendlich, die gleichen Kameras benutzen. Nur der eine darf halt aufnehmen und der andere nicht zum Beispiel.
So ist das.
Aber wie ist denn das? Hast du das schon irgendwie resigniert? Hast du das schon aufgegeben mit deinen Bekannten darüber zu diskutieren? Oder probierst du es dann ab und zu auch nochmal?
Na wenn man es ihnen dann sagt, dann kommen die Leute ja schon ins Grübeln. Also dann, wie gesagt, es fällt einem halt einfach nicht so auf. Weil es halt nicht, in der DDR hat man halt genau gewusst. Man musste theoretisch auffassen, was man sagt und konnte nicht machen, was man will. Aber hier hat man ja den Eindruck, dass man, es gibt ja, merkt man ja, die Leute haben immer den Eindruck, ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen. Deswegen kann ich ja irgendwie und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass ich irgendwie überwacht werde oder irgendwie, dass mir irgendjemand was will. Und ist doch alles wunderbar. Und wenn man den Leuten das dann sagt, dann fangen sie halt schon irgendwann mal an zu denken.
Hast du mal irgendwie das Thema Handy-Kameras angesprochen? Ich meine, es gibt immer so, es ist ein bisschen zweischneidig. Du hast halt auf der einen Seite irgendwie die Polizei und die Behörden und was weiß ich wen, die Interesse an Videodaten haben, aber es wurde ja auch schon thematisiert, wie sich das jetzt mit der privaten Überwachung so verhält. Also ich kann mich erinnern, letztes Jahr gab es irgendwie einen Vorstoß von irgendeiner Politikerin, die meinte irgendwie, dass mit diesen Handy-Kameras, ja das müsste man ein bisschen eindämmen. Das uffert aus, da machen halt Leute Aufnahmen und schicken die halt per MMS irgendwie an alle möglichen Freunde und das geht ja gar nicht.
Ich glaube, Handy-Kameras sind ja eigentlich eine Sache. Handy-Kameras sind ja hip. Das ist ja eigentlich, ich glaube, 95 Prozent der Fotos, die damit gemacht werden, zeigen wahrscheinlich nur irgendwelche Besoffenen, die auf irgendeiner Party gerade irgendwo in der Ecke liegen.
Und die haben es eh nicht besser verdient, ne?
Genau.
Gut, aber auch die Leute, die da besoffen in der Ecke liegen, möchten wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt, dass irgendwie eine Woche später ihr Bild irgendwo im Internet auf einer, wir hatten hier eine lustige Party und guckt mal, wie f*** die alle haben.
Ja gut, aber das gab es ja immer, dass da irgendwie die Besoffenen dann hinterher mit einem Adding angemalt wurden und dann die Fotos da irgendwie...
Also www.betrunkene.de dekorieren die irgendwie.
Ja, aber die Hemmschulle ist doch jetzt irgendwie deutlich gesunken, wenn jeder irgendwie so einen Teil in der Tasche hat. Früher musste man irgendwie noch zum Foto, also zum Entwickeln gehen und hat man sich vielleicht doch nicht getraut, wenn man eine schweinige Sache mit dem gemacht hat, wie heutzutage digital und irgendwie einmal rauslutschen und fertig ist.
Webcams sind ja auch out, aber irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren hatte ja wirklich auch jeder in der Webcam zu Hause stehen und hat sich dann gefilmt, wie er da vorm Rechner sitzt. Ich glaube, die Leute finden das eher noch vielleicht so ein bisschen Selbstdarstellung, die er noch behält.
Privat-Kübelböck-Gleichsam. Andreas, vielen Dank fürs lange Warten und deinen Anruf.
Ja, auf Wieder.
Gute Nacht, tschüss. Wir haben zum Beispiel, der Stefan hat gefragt, wie das aussieht. Im Gesetz steht hier drin, dass eine unverzügliche Datenlöschung vorgeschrieben ist. Ob denn diese ganze Überwachungssache nicht irgendwie dann absurdum geführt wird, wenn dann die Sachen sowieso wieder gelöscht werden. Was heißt denn eigentlich unverzüglich, Nils?
Das war eben schon das Problem. Das ist wahrscheinlich genau dasselbe, wie das man nur überholen darf, wenn man mit erheblich höherer Geschwindigkeit überholt. Weiß auch keiner, was das ist.
Ja, das ist eben so ein unbestimmter Rechtsbegriff. Ich kann nur aus der Praxis erzählen. Also hier zum Beispiel das Kaufhaus, das Kulturkaufhaus Dussmann, wie es heißt in Berlin, gleichzeitig ein großer Sicherheitskonzern, dem dieses Kulturkaufhaus gehört, ist eben der Meinung unverzüglich bedeutet, dass sie nicht nur mehrere Tage, sondern auch gleich Wochen die Bilder speichern dürfen. Und der Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragte aber ist der Meinung, dass unverzüglich eben bedeutet, allenfalls wenige Tage. Das ist einfach umstritten. Und es setzt ein Poker ein, wenn es zum Streitfall kommt, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Und es gibt zurzeit noch keine endgültige Entscheidung. Das ist unglücklich.
Warum nicht? Also wie stellt man das her? Die Rechtssicherheit über den Begriff unverzüglich?
Zum einen müsste das in einem konkreten Streitfall, in einem Prozess auch mal der Gegenstand der Auseinandersetzung sein. Hätten diese Daten gelöscht werden müssen. Zum anderen müssten sozusagen die Datenschutzbeauftragten selber dann auch konfrontativ in einem Streitfall mal sich durchsetzen und sagen, nein, du hättest das Ding löschen müssen. Und dann würde dadurch auch eine Klarstellung erzielt werden. Zum Zeitpunkt verhalten sich alle windelweich, weil es einfach diese Videoüberwachung ufert völlig aus. Das ist wirklich wie Unkraut. Du spriehst es an allen Ecken und Enden, diese Kameras aus der Erde, aus den Wänden. Und das ist einfach keiner mag da noch laut auf den Tisch schauen und sagen hier, dass das sowas in die Regel ist.
Warum tun die Datenschützer das nicht? Sind das nur Papiertiger? Also dann können wir sie auch abschaffen, oder?
Die sind total überfordert. Die haben zu wenig Personal, zu wenig Geld, um ihren Job zu tun. Und eigentlich müssten die genauso entsprechend den technischen Möglichkeiten, die sich auch verändert haben und viel besser geworden sind. Kameras kosten ja nichts mehr. Entsprechend müssten die auch besser ausgerüstet werden. Aber dazu ist die Politik nicht bereit.
Aber du hast was dagegen getan. Kannst du vielleicht mal kurz ein bisschen schildern zum Dussmann-Urteil?
Also ich selber war das nicht. Ich hatte einen Mandanten, einen Journalisten, der gegen die Videoüberwachung auf den Gehsteigen vor dem Kulturkaufhaus Dussmann auf der Berliner Friedrichstraße geklagt hat. Weil er da jeden Morgen durchläuft, sozusagen auf dem Weg zur Arbeit. Und er will das einfach nicht, dass ihm da sozusagen permanent an jeder Hauswand, wo er vorbeiläuft, eine Kamera über die Schulter schaut. Dann hat er gesagt, hier, das will ich nicht. Dann hat er da hingeschrieben, hat gesagt, hängt diese Kameras ab, das ist ein öffentlicher Gehsteig, ihr dürft da nicht filmen. Und als die andere Seite, Dussmann, sich geweigert hat, diese Kameras abzuhängen, hat er geklagt. Und jetzt hat eben das Amtsgericht hier in Berlin entschieden, dass im Grundsatz private die öffentlichen Gehsteige nicht filmen dürfen. Das ist nicht deren Land. Die dürfen allenfalls bis zu ihrer Hausgrenze eigentlich filmen. Gegebenenfalls auch noch einen kleinen Streifen davor, einen Meter. Aber darüber hinaus darf nicht gefilmt werden.
Es sind dabei rausgekommen, wie weit auf die Straße hinaus Dussmann filmt?
Anfangs war es so, dass Dussmann gefilmt hat bis zu unter den Linden. Das war also 100 Meter entfernt. Da hatte auch der Anwalt der Gegenseite sich vor Gericht gebrüstet, dass man doch habe helfen können, als im Juwelierladen 100 Meter entfernt ein versuchter Einbruch war. Man hat also sozusagen offen vor Gericht bekannt gegeben, dass man sich rechtswidrig verhalten hat.
Das ist groß.
Wenn Fritz Info halten sehen, dann 100 2, 6.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht ist es wolkig, es gibt einzelne Schneeschauer. Die Temperaturen sinken auf minus zwei bis minus fünf Grad. Auch morgen erwarten uns immer mal wieder leichte Schneeschauer. Die Höchstwerte dann um den Gefrierpunkt.
Und jetzt die Meldung mit Krischer See der Elfen.
In Brandenburg hat es im letzten Jahr offenbar mehr rechte Gewalttaten gegeben. Das berichtet der Tagesspiegel. Insgesamt habe die Polizei 87 Gewalttaten gezählt. Das waren sechs mehr als im Vorjahr. Die Gewaltreiche von Brandstiftungen bis hin zum versuchten Mord. Bereitschaftsdienste in Krankenhäusern zählen als Arbeitszeit. Sie müssen aber nicht voll bezahlt werden. Das hat das Bundesarbeitsgericht in Erfurt entschieden. Die Arbeitnehmer würden in diesen Zeiten weniger beansprucht, deshalb sei es zulässig, dass sie dann auch weniger Geld bekommen. Im Tarifstreit der Metall- und Elektroindustrie soll es ab 0 Uhr in Berlin die ersten Bahnstreiks geben. Die IG Metall hat die Nachtschicht in den Ostram Werken in Spandau zu Bahnstreiks aufgerufen. Morgen Vormittag sollen da Beschäftigte von Daimler Chrysler in Marienfelde die Arbeit niederlegen. In Großbritannien gibt es nach dem Abschluss zur Kelly-Affäre die ersten personellen Konsequenzen. Der Vorstand der BBC Davis hat seinen Rücktritt eingereicht. Die Untersuchung hatte ergeben, dass die BBC im Unrecht war. Sie hatte berichtet, die berittische Regierung habe ein Irak-Dossier aufgebaut. Und noch eine Meldung vom Sport. Bei der Handball-Europameisterschaft hat Deutschland gegen Gastgeber Slowenien mit 31 zu 24 gewonnen. Damit reiche den Deutschen morgen ein Unentschieden gegen Ungarn, um ins Halbfinale zu kommen. Und der Verkehr auf Ritz? Momentan keine Meldung, fahrt schön vorsichtig.
Ey, wir suchen doch jetzt den Klops der Klöpse, den ganz großen Käse. Also mach's mal ein bisschen größer.
Wer wird Großmeisterdreister Musik und fliegt zu den Brit Awards nach London? Spielt mit, stellvertretend für eure Firma, Schule, Uni oder was auch immer. Dann kommt die mobile Meisterprüfung in Dreister Musik direkt zu euch.
Jetzt mitmachen unter fritz.de. Einfach musste klicken, klicken.
Und am 13. Februar gibt's dann das große Meisterdreister-Musik-Finale in den Fritz Studios. Da fällt die Entscheidung, wer wird Großmeisterdreister-Musik und fliegt zu den Brit Awards nach London.
Von der Teilnahme ausgeschlossen sind Trommelfelmützenträger und Seniorenohren. Und im Radio?
Dreieste Musik?
Chaosradio 88 und im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Ein Lieblingslied von Frank.
Wir haben es deswegen gespielt, wir haben es deswegen rausgesucht, weil es gibt einen Kriminalistenpsychologen, der heißt Detlef Nagola, der ist auch für das Zitat in der Ankündigung für die Radiesendung verantwortlich. Der hat einen Text geschrieben, der heißt der Frosch im heißen Wasser und erklärt ein bisschen oder versucht zu erklären, wie das eigentlich kommt, dass wir uns langsam an diese Videoüberwachung und an die Gesamtüberwachung in der Gesellschaft gewöhnen. Da führt er dieses Lied Every Breath You Take auch als Beispiel an, vor allem den Refrain. Da ist eigentlich sehr schön das aufgelistet, was wir hier eigentlich so bereden, nämlich Every Move You Make, das heißt es geht um Bewegungsprofile oder es geht um alles Mögliche. I'll be watching you, das steht allgemein stellvertretend für unsere Sendung.
Das mit dem Frosch erklärst du jetzt auch noch, schließlich hast du es angerissen.
Ja, da sind wir auch schon freundlicherweise von einem Hörer vor der Sendung drauf hingewiesen worden, dass das eigentlich biologischer total Quatsch ist, weil die Frösche dann trotzdem irgendwann aus dem Wasser springen.
Wir fangen jetzt mit der Geschichte von vorne an. Also es gibt so diese urbane Legende, dass wenn man einen Frosch in kochendes Wasser wirft, dieser Frosch sofort raus hüpfen wird, wohingegen, wenn man den Frosch in warmes Wasser setzt und langsam die Temperatur erhöht, der Frosch da drin bleiben wird und kocht. Das ist Quatsch.
Erklärt aber zumindestens, warum wir uns langsam an die Videoüberwachung gewöhnen. Also es gibt Leute, so ich denke, der Aufschrei so beim ersten Big Brother Container war Überwachung und Privatsphäre und irgendwie Menschenrechte, lalalala.
Ich fand's geil.
Und Slutko nach vorne.
Nee, Manu raus. Mittlerweile ist es alles völlig normal und auch über Videokameras regt sich niemand auf und denkt, ja die sind halt da und es wird schon nichts passieren und ich hab ja auch nichts zu verbergen. Und das ist eigentlich das, was wir ja auch heute diskutieren wollten neben den technischen Aspekten von Videoüberwachung und Kennzeichenerfassung und weiß nicht was. Habt ihr euch eigentlich schon an die Videoüberwachung gewöhnt? Wollt ihr euch daran gewöhnt? Findet ihr das gut? Wenn ja, warum, wenn nein, wo ist das Problem bei euch?
Und diskutiert wird unter 0331 70 97 110. Bitte habt Verständnis dafür, wenn ihr lange in der Warteschleife hängen müsst. Wir haben sehr viele Anrufer und selbst auch sehr viel zu erzählen. Der Boris, der hat lange gewartet. Vielen Dank dafür und nichts für ungut.
Also ich wollte jetzt mal grundsätzlich, weil schon vieles gesagt wurde jetzt erstmal wegen dieser Videoüberwachung sagen, dass ich das jetzt nicht als so kritisch empfinde. Vor allem denke ich, dass das auch schon wirklich lang da war. Und in der Öffentlichkeit hat man eh, wie gesagt, muss man sich in gewisse Regeln halten und um mich jetzt da Kamera irgendwo in der Bank auf dem Postamt oder im Supermarkt aufnimmt, ist man jetzt eigentlich ziemlich schnuppe. Wo es bei mir irgendwo so die Grenze ist, wenn man jetzt von Heimüberwachung redet, also mein Zuhause, wobei das natürlich erst dann eigentlich passieren kann oder sollte, wenn mir man schon irgendwas nachweisen kann. Und also wo ich eigentlich mehr denke, dass da vielleicht mehr im Hintergrund passiert, sind Telefonüberwachungen, wo dann halt automatisch irgendwas geschaltet wird, ja der Anrufer so und so und da werden die und die wieder verwendet und das wird dann eben ausgewertet. Und da denke ich, ist eigentlich die Gefahr. Also bei einer Videoüberwachung kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt irgendwie ins Privatleben Eingriff nimmt oder so.
Na, das kann aber dazu führen. Ich meine bei der Telefonüberwachung, wenn du halt irgendwie die verdächtige Worte sagst und halt irgendwie, obwohl du nichts Schlimmes vorhast sozusagen irgendwie auf in den Fokus gerätst, sowas kann ja halt mit Videoüberwachung genauso passieren. So wenn du halt irgendwie, es gibt so dieses Anwendungsbeispiel, Personentracking auf Parkplätzen, so da gibt es halt einen sehr definierten Bereich, was man halt so auf einem Parkplatz macht, sprich man geht zum Auto oder man kommt vom Auto oder was auch immer, so und irgendwie da gibt es halt Systeme, die tracken dich dann halt. Und was ist, wenn du jetzt so irgendwie dreimal um vier verschiedene Autos rumläufst?
Also es könnte schon sein, dass irgendwie wenn du dich nach vorne beugst, in deinem Schuh zuzumachen, dass deine Sicherheitsdienst ankommt, weil das halt ein untypisches Verhalten ist für den Parkplatz.
Na gut, da kommst du natürlich dann mal auf, wo ich mich bewege, nehme ich immer an, wenn ich vielleicht in der Banken hinwöge, in der Warteschlange und mein Schuh zu mache, ist das vielleicht das andere als, wenn ich das jetzt irgendwo auf einem öffentlichen Platz mache.
Na ja, vielleicht.
Es hängt immer davon ab, wem dieser Platz gehört, also wem dieser Parkplatz gehört und was der für sicherheitsrelevant hält und was nicht, oder?
Ja genau, und ja da sehe ich auch, was schon mal angesprochen wurde, dass es eben private Überwachung gibt und eben diese öffentliche, was dann eben von eben jetzt Banken oder Postämtern oder was, was ich ausgehe. Wenn ich mich eben in einer Räumlichkeit befinde, wo ich sozusagen Kunde bin, wo ich mich dementsprechend aufzuwählen habe, da finde ich es schon okay. Aber wenn jetzt, wo diese Klage schon mal da war, wo man eben auf dem Bürgersteig überwacht wird, irgendwo sowas finde ich natürlich nicht okay. Also da ist schon ein Punkt, wo ich dann sage, da sollte man irgendwie dann mal einlenken.
Aber stell doch mal vor, du bist irgendwie in der Post und da wird gerade was geklaut und irgendwie nachträglich verwerten sie die Videobilder aus und sehen irgendwie du, du und du, die waren irgendwie zu der Zeit in der Post. Und sie wissen aber nicht, wie er das geklaut hat. Da kommen sie irgendwie erst mal zu dir durchsuchen deine Wohnung und irgendwie das findest du bestimmt auch nicht toll, oder?
Nö, das finde ich natürlich nicht toll.
Aber das kann passieren.
Ja, na gut, okay, das ist dann wahrscheinlich Zufall, da hat man dann Pech, na das ist schon klar. Ja, das sind so Sachen, klar, da denkt man natürlich nicht drüber nach, das muss ich schon zugeben, ne?
Ja, aber um genau diese Fälle, um diese Grenzfälle geht das ja halt auch. Irgendwie auch an diesen Fällen muss sich halt irgendwie so ein System messen lassen.
Ich finde aber trotzdem, dass der Boris Recht hat in dem Sinne, dass er versucht, einfach abzustufen zu sagen, welcher Ort, wir müssen ganz konkret gucken, welcher Ort wird denn überwacht. Und ist es nicht in bestimmten Einzelfällen so, dass vielleicht doch es in diesem einen oder anderen Fall verhältnismäßig sein kann? Und dass wir einfach unterscheiden müssen. Aber trotzdem würde ich dann nochmal die Überlegung entgegenhalten, was ist denn mit dem bloßen Willen, der dagegen entgegensteht? Wenn einer sagt, ich will das nicht, dass ich jetzt hier überwacht werde, dann ist das auch alleine schon ein Moment. Ich meine, es muss nicht immer nur darum gehen, dass da eine konkrete Missbrauchsmöglichkeit im Raum steht, dass diese Daten weitergegeben werden, dass ich da falsch verdächtigt werde, sondern nach unserem Verständnis von Menschsein geht es auch darum, dass einer sagt, ich will das nicht, dass ich dauernd überwacht werde, auch an diesem und jedem Ort nicht, und dann ist das auch alleine schon erheblich.
Es gibt ein paar Örtlichkeiten, wo mir das auffällt.
Ich persönlich, ich denke, es läuft vielleicht viel im Hintergrund ab.
Mir ist jetzt nicht oft bewusst gewesen, dass ich an irgendwelchen Orten gefilmt werde. Also wenn ich jetzt natürlich irgendwo an Orten war, wo es offensichtlich ist, dann schon, aber ich wüsste nicht, dass ich hier, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo von mir aus in der Stadt rumlaufe, wo ich jetzt da auf Video aufgenommen werde. Und solange ich denke ich nichts tue, was jetzt irgendwie auf eine Strafe hindeutet oder auf ein Vergehen oder irgendwas, denke ich, habe ich doch kein Problem damit.
Das Problem ist doch, dass du gar nicht weißt, ob du nicht vielleicht doch etwas tust, was auf eine Straftat hindeutet. Weil das ja immer im Ermessen desjenigen liegt, der dich beobachtet, ob er dir unterstellt, dass du eine Straftat vorbereitest oder ob du das nicht tust.
Ja gut, gut, schon, aber ich meine, das ist ja dann gut. Da schneidet er sich doch ins eigene Fleisch, wenn er eine Videoüberwachung hat. Und ich hab angeblich auf diesen Bildern irgendwas getan, dann ist es ja wohl mit diesen Bildern auch entweder zu beweisen oder zu widerlegen. Also ich denke, das ist doch dann Beweis genug. Also da kann man ja doch mit Videoüberwachung nichts anhängen.
Doch, Unannehmlichkeiten.
Du machst dann die Scherereien.
Wie eben gesagt, da kommt jemand, durchsucht deine Wohnung, oder du wirst vorgeladen und vernommen, was auch immer. Es sind Scherereien, die sie dir machen können damit.
Vor allem wenn du irgendwie echt ein Feind, also ich weiß nicht, ob es sowas wirklich gibt, aber so ein richtiger privater Feind, der kann dir da irgendwie echt ans Bein pissen und du hast dann irgendwie keinen Spaß mehr mit deinem Leben, weil er dir irgendwie so viel Mist in die Schuhe schiebt. Also ich meine, das muss man halt einfach auch sehen, so ein Gefahrenpotenzial besteht dabei einfach.
Also das Problem ist einfach, wenn du wirklich 24 Stunden am Tag irgendwie überwacht wirst, du wirst auf jeden Fall mal irgendeine Bewegung machen, die, wo du dir später wünscht, dass du sie vielleicht nicht gemacht hättest vor der Kamera.
Wenn du nur ein Popel unter dem Sitz im Bus schwiegst.
Genau, was mir dann später vielleicht vorgeworfen hat.
Ja, okay, das ist wohl wahr, aber ich denke, was auch angesprochen wurde, diese aktive Abschreckung, das ist, denke ich, das ist auf jeden Fall ein positiver Faktor. Also da würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, dafür ist es gut, also an den dementsprechenden Orten halt, ne. Zum Beispiel jetzt auf dem Postamt, muss ich immer wieder sagen, weil da ist es mir letztens wieder aufgefallen, da hängt wirklich eine dicke Kamera.
Aber es gibt trotzdem Banküberfälle.
Ja, und ich meine...
Alle werden aufgeklärt.
Ja schon, aber ich meine, ich frage mich halt auch, es kommt darauf an, wobei jedem die Hemmschwelle dann auch ist, ne. Also ob jetzt jemand sich irgendwie von der Kamera davon abhalten lässt, ob er jetzt mit dem Gedanken spielt, naja, ich könnte das Posteramt ausrauben, mir geht eh nix voran halt, dann nehme ich wenigstens den Kohle mit. Dann zieht er die Kamera und denkt sich, na okay, ich lasse es lieber, weil da bin ich halt eben auf Video.
Was tun denn die Bankräuber? Die setzen sich einen Helm auf. Und toll, die hat die Kamera genau gar nichts gebracht.
Aber glaubst du dann wirklich, dass sich jemand denn genau davon abschrecken lässt, der eine Bank überfällt?
Ja gut, ich denke, jemand der eine Bank überfällt und das Plan wird das auch geschickter machen. Der wird jetzt nicht unbedingt sich da vor die Kamera stellen und eben keine sich nicht so im Moment. Ich denke schon, dass da mehr dahinter steckt, dass das auch besser geplant ist, wenn man es von ihm gesichtspunkt.
Und wenn denn, ist es ihm auch egal?
Stimmt auch wieder. Was ich noch sagen wollte ist, diese Geschichte um diese Frau, die in die USA einreisen wollte und wo dann eben von Amazon diese Liste kam, von wegen sie hat die anti-amerikanischen Bücher gekauft. Das finde ich auch ein Hammer, das ist ein Punkt, wenn der Mensch dann so gläsern wird, dass man ihm mit einem Knopfdruck sofort diese ganzen Geschichten irgendwo abrufen kann über ihn, das ist natürlich brutal. Also diese vernetzten Geschichten eben, also nicht nur Videoüberwachung, sondern eben auch, dass es eine Datenbank gibt über das Verhalten im Internet, vielleicht über Telefonate und Videoüberwachung und und und. Dass das dann zu quasi einer Datenbank oder zum Abbild des Menschen führt, das finde ich irgendwo den Punkt, wo es mir dann schon ein wenig mulmig wird, wo ich dann denke, das ist nicht mehr so toll.
Alles klar Boris, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. So, wer auch ewig warten muss und darum kommt da ran, ist der Philipp.
Ja, ich hatte das Thema mit den Telefonsälen, also das ist mehr eine Frage. Und zwar habe ich gemerkt, dass in der Stadt diese Säulen, also die nicht mehr vier Wände haben, oben über dem Dach gibt es in manchen davon ein kleines Loch und da sehe ich sowas wie eine Linse. Also ich habe zumindest den Eindruck, dass es eine ist.
Warte mal, wovon redest du jetzt genau?
Die Telefonstangen, die Telefonhäuschen, so Rogat.
Ja die, die nicht mehr vier Wände und eine Tür haben.
Also, also, wüssten wir nicht. Also wir gehen natürlich jetzt gleich auf dem Heimweg mal gucken, aber...
Ja, also ich habe das vor allem gegenüber von einer Disko bemerkt und am Kottmossatur auch noch. Also das sind dann wirklich kleine Löcher und wenn man da reinguckt, dann sieht das aus wie eine Linse, also wie von einer Kamera.
Kleb doch einfach mal zu und warte, was passiert.
Genau. Hab ich schon immer, genau das war meine erste Idee, hab ich aber noch nie gemacht.
Sind die an jeder Telefonzelle denn?
Nein, die sind nicht an jeder dran, die sind teilweise nur.
Also müsste es sein. Wenn da eine Kamera wäre, müsste da ein Schild sein.
Müsste.
Aber ist doch klar, erkennen wir, dass da eine Kamera ist, sieht doch jeder sofort, hat die Bundesregierung jedenfalls gesagt. Wozu? Es gab mal eine Anfrage der PDS, so eine offizielle Anfrage, an die Bundesregierung, wie dies denn so hält mit der Videoüberwachung an ihren Gebäuden, also am Bundestag und an Verwaltungsgebäuden und so was. Und die haben gesagt, naja, also die Frage war, ob das dann irgendwie kennzeichnet wird oder ob die denn irgendwie erkennbar sein müssen. Und meinte die Bundesregierung, nö, das ist doch offensichtlich, dass da welche hängen, die sieht man doch, die brauchen wir nicht extra ausschildern. Und interessant waren auch die Zahlen übrigens dazu. Ich habe da mal nachgerechnet, die haben also auch die ganzen Kameras aufgelistet. Es ist also so, dass jeder Standort, jeder Standort hat also Durchschnitt. Es gibt da so eine bestimmte Anzahl pro Kamera, 800 Kameras, die die da insgesamt haben, und teilt durch die Standorte. Und da kommt halt so viel raus, dass die ungefähr oder ein kleines bisschen mehr Kameras pro Standort haben, als im ersten Big Brother Container waren. Und wen überwachen die sich selbst?
Ich meine, ist ja in Ordnung, dann kriegen sie vielleicht mal mit, wer von den ganzen Abgeordneten Alkoholiker ist und wer nicht. Oder wen überwachen die? Also wie weit gucken die über den Reichstag hinaus?
Naja, es geht natürlich auch um Gebäude. Es geht um Sachbeschädigung internationaler Terrorismus.
Die schönste und gleichzeitig dämlichste Floskel zum Thema internationaler Terrorismus war übrigens der Begriff Islamistischer Netzwerk-Terrorismus. Eier legende Wollmilchsau.
Naja, also mit den Kameras an Telefonsstellen werden wir überprüfen. Schauen wir mal nach, falls da noch jemand irgendwie sowas entdeckt hat, schickt uns eine Mail an 88.chaosradio.ccc.de oder ruft an.
Falls uns gerade irgendwelche Telekom-Mitarbeiter zuhören.
Genau, vielleicht könnt ihr auch erklären, was es ist.
Genau, wir wissen, dass ihr das bisweilen tut. Ruft mal an unter 0331 77 97 110 und erzählt uns, was das für Kameras sind, die in so mancher Telefonzelle eingebaut sind. Philipp, vielen Dank für diesen Tipp.
Ich will meine Sache zu London sagen. Und zwar, das ist ja immer diese Sache, dass das so ein toll überwachtes Urwandsystem ist. Und ich hab da noch eine Geschichte, und zwar, also das hab ich über Graffiti zum Beispiel gelesen, ist, dass dort die Stationen, wo diese Züge dann platziert werden in der Nacht, eigentlich auch mit Kameras ausgeschaltet sind und Bewegungsmeldern. Und das niemand mehr abgehalten hat, denn die Leute, die da früher als Wachdienst waren, wurden dadurch abgeschafft. Und die Leute sind doch dann halt rein diese früher und wusst. Sie sind einfach um die Bewegungsmelle herumgelaufen. Sie hatten es ja irgendwann erkannt, dass sie dort waren und dann konnten sie dann Ruhe malen.
Genau, die Anpassung. Aber zum Thema, im England hab ich irgendwie ein paar lustige Zahlen. In England gibt es irgendwie mehr als 4 Millionen Kameras, das heißt irgendwie auf 14 Engländer kommt eine Kamera. Also irgendwie 14 Engländer, irgendwie eine Kamera. Und in England stehen ein Fünftel der gesamten Weltkamera auf Koms und 70 Prozent davon sind nicht gekennzeichnet. Also nur mal so ein paar Zahlen. Aber einfach mal 14 Engländer auf eine Kamera.
Gibt es hier Zahlen für Deutschland?
Nur sehr vage.
Circa 500.000, das ist aber eine Schätzung, die ich für viel zu gering halte.
Ich würde gerne mal wieder eine…
Eine Sekunde noch, wir haben einen Telekom-Mitarbeiter. Hallo, Jens.
Hallöchen, guten Abend.
Baut ihr Kameras in Telefonzellen?
Telefonzellen würde ich dann zunächst mal sagen.
Also Basis-Telefon heißen wir jetzt.
Basis-Telefon.
Basis-Telefonistischer islamistischer Netzwerk.
Erzähl, was ist das da oben drinnen?
Also offiziell eigentlich nicht.
Ich kann mir bloß denken, dass das halt so Schwerpunkte sind, wo halt mal gerne demoliert wird. Und dann halt die Täter gefasst werden sollen.
Komposator, ja.
Weil mit der Telefonseite natürlich auch nicht grad günstig.
Da gehen wir mal gucken.
Kannst du das vielleicht rausfinden?
Kann mich mal umhören.
Also dann einfach in der Mail schreiben. Also vor allem, dass ist interessant. Vor allem, wo die Daten hingehen. Genau, gekennzeichnet werden und wo die Daten hingehen, ob die aufgezeichnet werden.
Also ich kann mich mal umhören bei den Kollegen.
Ja super, eine Mail dann an 88 at chaosradio.ccc.de.
Kann ich mir sogar noch merken.
Ich hab da noch eine kurze Frage, wenn ich darf.
Und zwar ist mir aufgefallen, dass bei den Kölner Verkehrsbetrieben neuerdings auch überall Videokameras rumhängen in den Haltestationen. Und mir ist da bis jetzt noch nicht wirklich ein Hinweis aufgefallen, dass da irgendwie überwacht wird.
Ja doch, irgendwie mittlerweile geht man auch dazu über Haltestellen.
Ja, mach ich ja. Also Neumarkt vor allem und halt alles, was im Innenstadtbereich ist.
Moment, also wenn ihr im Neumarkt die Haltestellen überwacht, überwacht ihr den gesamten Neumarkt?
Nee, ich meine jetzt unterirdisch.
Über oberirdisch fahre ich kaum.
Aber wie gesagt, da hängen halt Videokameras und die fallen zwar auf, aber mir ist da nicht wirklich nirgends aufgefallen, dass da halt schreiben, ja wir überwachen hier mit Video.
Ja, würde ich mal an die NRW Datenschutzbeauftragte weitergeben an deiner Stelle, die ist zuständig. Die müsste auch mit denen dann mal ein Wörtchen reden.
Okay, werde ich tun.
Alles klar, vielen Dank Jens. Und guten Abend Alex. Du hast eine Telefonzelle genauer untersucht.
Ja, ich hab mir so ein Ding mal ein bisschen näher angeguckt, als ich Wartezeit hatte auf dem Bus. Und das sah mir also aus hinter diesem Auge. Also es ist ja so ein rundes Loch mit einer Glasscheibe davor. Und dahinter sah das halt aus wie ein Foto Widerstand. Also was man auch an der Hausnummer leuchtet oder so hat.
Wie groß ist das ungefähr?
Dass es Licht angeht, das klingt plausibel.
Also um jetzt die Telefonzelle zu überwachen, ob da jemand den Hörer abreißt oder sowas, bringt das ja nichts. Weil das Ding ist zu hoch, also das guckt ja praktisch drüber weg in die Landschaft und nicht. Also das wäre irgendwie ziemlich zwecklos.
Also man kann es trotzdem auswählen. Klebst du zu, dann müsste es Licht angehen, oder?
Ja klar, das wäre der entscheidende Test.
Tschüss, machs gut. Und ein paar Mails von Frank noch.
Und zwar hat er Bernd gefragt, wenn er mit seiner Freundin bei einer pikanten Situation auf der Straße oder irgendwo...
Poppen. Poppen in der Öffentlichkeit.
Genau, wenn er dabei gefilmt wird.
Das gehört sich aber doch gar nicht.
Das könnte schon mal passieren. Wenn er dabei gefilmt wird, oder auch beim berühmten Nasepopeln, und das erscheint dann irgendwann im Fernsehen, wen muss er denn da eigentlich verklagen?
Ja, man muss jetzt genau schauen, wenn es um die Verbreitung der Bilder geht, dann geht es eben darum, möglicherweise Schadensersatz bekommen zu wollen von dem Verantwortlichen, der diese Bilder an die Medien zum Beispiel gegeben hat. Und die machen daraus dann Videotape, was dann Caught in Action oder so heißt, so wie es in England schon gibt.
Ist es notwendig, dass er dabei drauf zu erkennen ist, zu identifizieren, oder reicht es, wenn er allein in der Situation, wenn er sich selbst wieder erkennt?
Gelten die Persönlichkeitsrechte auch für meinen Arsch?
Ja, also ich glaube, da müsste schon der Personenbezug da sein, damit man dann überhaupt mit dem Persönlichkeitsrecht, das ist dann die Anspruchsgrundlage, kommen kann. Also da muss eben die Persönlichkeit so abgebildet sein, dass man wieder erkennbar ist für Dritte.
Dann gilt das auch für meinen Arsch.
Also gut, also das Problem ist aber, wenn ich da im Fernsehen gesehen habe, ich erzähl vielleicht auch meinen Freunden, oh super, hier tolle Nummer mit meiner Freundin, da im Gebüsch und so. Ja, wissen wir. Genau. Ach, dann warst du das Detlef diese Woche da auf dem drei Buchstaben Sender.
Ja, so ein ähnlicher Fall ist ja neulich mal wohl passiert in einem Kaufhaus in Hannover. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaub Jan, du kannst den Fall besser als ich. Da ging es um Media Markt und jemand, der da gefilmt wurde von der Hausvideoanlage. Und dessen Bild wurde dann an die Öffentlichkeit gegeben.
Das war die Geschichte mit der Mutter aller Schnäppchen. Die Mutter aller Schnäppchen ist ja die Werbefigur für den Media Markt. Und die ist im Promarkt einkaufen gegangen. Promarkt hat es gefilmt und hat genau dieses Bild benutzt, um Werbung für sich selbst zu machen. Guck mal, wo die Mutter aller Schnäppchen einkaufen geht. Und daraufhin hat die eben auch wegen Verletzungen der Persönlichkeitsrechte geklagt. Und ist, glaub ich, durchgekommen.
Genau, da würde ich es auch sagen, das ist ein klarer Fall, da ist einfach eine völlige Zweckentfremdung dieser Videoanlage gewesen. Man hat einfach die Bilder da missbraucht für einen anderen Zweck, nämlich um die Wettbewerber da in die Pfanne zu hauen. Und das geht natürlich nicht. Das ist ein Eingriff ins Persönlichkeitsrecht.
Wir haben ein paar Mails gekriegt von Leuten, die uns geschrieben haben, dass an ihrer Uni oder an ihrer Fachhochschule Videoüberwachung ganz hip ist, bzw. dass da ganz viele Kameras sind. Und die eigentlich nicht so richtig wissen, was damit jetzt ist. Da wird zwar gesagt, naja, die sind halt dazu da, um irgendwie die Hörsäle. Da gab es auch eine Geschichte an der Humboldt-Uni, die gesagt haben, naja, die sind halt dazu da, um zu gucken, ob der Ton dann richtig übertragen wird oder wie sie irgendwelche Einstellungen machen müssen. Oder es ist zu schauen, ob der Hörsaal vielleicht zu voll ist. Denen gibt es aber auch welche, die irgendwelche Rechnerarbeitsräume damit überwachen. Und irgendwie scheint die Unileitung aber auch nicht so richtig in der Lage zu sein, Auskunft zu geben, was jetzt genau da, was das soll, was mit den Daten passiert, wer da Zugriff drauf hat, wer sich das anschauen kann, ob sie gespeichert werden, wann sie gelöscht werden. Und ja, wie sind da so die rechtlichen Grundlagen oder wen kann man da im Zweifelsfall ansprechen?
Also bei der Humboldt-Uni, die zukünftige Elite-Uni Deutschlands, eine von vielen, da war es wirklich grotesk. Wir haben jeden Video-Saal, jeden Hörsaal hatten die mit einer Kamera ausgestattet und die vorderen Bänke wurden erfasst der Studenten, ohne dass sie das wussten und zwar über Jahre. Einmal gab es einen Fall, da war ein Gastdozent aus Amerika im Vorlesungssaal mit einer Kaffeetasse, die er sich geholt hatte und plötzlich kam eine Stimme aus dem Off und die sagte sehr geehrter Herr so und so mit dem roten Anorak, bitte nehmen Sie den Kaffee wieder raus. Bitte verlassen Sie den Hörsaal. Sie dürfen keinen Kaffee mit in den Hörsaal nehmen.
Nein, das ist nicht was Sie sagen.
Dieser Fall ist tatsächlich passiert. Und es hat jetzt eben vor kurzem den Streit gegeben, ein Student hat die Uni aufgefordert, diese Kameras in den Hörsaalen abzuhängen. Und als die Uni eine Klageandrohung bekommen hat, hat sie das sofort getan. Also wenn diese Kameras in den Hörsälen laufend eingeschaltet sind und die Studenten da mit erfasst werden, dann ist das natürlich ein Unding. Man muss sich das mal vorstellen, die Uni als Ort der freien Lehre und sozusagen der Bildung und des freien Diskurses und eine Kamera schnurrt immer mit. Völliger Wahnsinn. Hier ist wirklich die Grenze erreicht und das muss die Uni genau offenlegen, was sie da tut und warum sie...
Spätestens wenn die Uni die Elite ausspuckt, wird die Elite sich schon dagegen wehren, dass sie damals und...
Ja, offen.
Vielleicht, ja. Jo, wir haben auch noch ein paar Mails bekommen zum Thema Kennzeichenüberwachung und Erfassung von Autos. Da meinte auch jemand zum Beispiel, dass die Kameras, die an den Ampeln sind, dass wir da gar nicht so eine Panik machen sollen, dass die Kameras, die an den Ampeln angebracht sind, nur dazu da sind, um die Ampeln zu steuern. Das ist natürlich richtig, wobei es auch keine wirklichen Kameras sind, in dem Sinne, wie eine Videoüberwachung sind, sondern die sind wirklich dazu da, um zu erkennen, ob da jetzt Stau entsteht oder so, was für wir die Ampeln schalten müssen. Darum geht es aber nicht. Ne, ist das einfach so, dass im Rahmen der LKW-Maut sind ja auch Kontrollbrücken aufgebaut. Jeder, der irgendwie schon mal Autobahnen gefahren ist in der letzten Zeit, das läuft hier gerade im Fernsehen, wunderbar. Da sind Kontrollbrücken aufgebaut worden, ungefähr 300 Stück in Deutschland. Das Ding sieht aus wie eine Mega-Radar-Falle. Also ganz riesig groß, stehen ganz bedrohlich über der Autobahn. Und da sind auch ganz viele Kameras drin. Und diese Kamerabrücken sollen erfassen, ob LKW-Fahrer ihre Maut nicht bezahlt haben. Beziehungsweise die Kontrollierenden, diese sogenannte Onboard-Unit, ob die zählt, ob die scharf geschaltet ist. Und wenn es nicht ist, dann wird der LKW erfasst. Und da sind Systeme drin, die von einer Firma hergestellt werden, die ursprünglich überhaupt so Kennzeichen, also Erkennungssysteme, Kennzeichen-Erfassungssysteme konzipiert hat. Und diese Erfassungssysteme werden tatsächlich auch eingesetzt. Die sind an mehreren Projekten schon getestet worden. Und sind als wirklich gut funktionierend bezeichnet worden. Das heißt, sie gehen also auch, wenn es neblig ist, wenn da verdreckte Kennzeichen sind. Das ist also ganz erstaunlich, wie die Erkennungsrate ist, sagen zumindest die Hersteller. Aber auch schon die Polizei hat es bestätigt, dass sie mit dem System eigentlich sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht haben.
Noch einen Eintrag. Ich hab einen Eintrag im Fritz-Board gefunden. Und zwar schreibt jemand, arbeite auch bei einem Sicherheitsdienst in der Friedrichstraße. Wir haben den Überfall auf den Juwelier auch gefilmt. Die Polizei hat sich gefreut und es hat niemanden interessiert, ob das okay war. Selbst die Polizei, die müssten die nicht eigentlich sagen, ja sorry, aber so nicht.
Nö, da tun die natürlich nicht. Die freuen sich über jeden Zulieferade. Es ist aber auch tatsächlich rechtlich so, dass sie auf private Filmaufnahmen zugreifen können. Sie können auch sagen, gebt uns das raus, das Beweismaterial ist schon richtig.
Das sind die Partner der Polizei. Holger, kennst du das? Partner der Polizei, das ist so ein Sticker, so ein Slogan.
Partner der Polizei? Ich kenne nur die alten Aufkleber. Hälfte der Polizei verprügelt euch selbst.
Nein, das habe ich gesehen auf einem Auto von einem privaten Sicherheitsdienst. Da gibt es jetzt einen Aufkleber, Partner der Polizei. Also wie so offiziell so ein Branding. Ich habe im Internet auch leider nichts dazu gefunden. Also vielleicht, wenn da jemand einen Hinweis hat, ob es irgendwie diese Erklärung dafür gibt, was das ist, wer dahinter steckt oder sowas, kann ja mal eine Mail schreiben.
Kann aber auch sein, dass das nur Poserei ist. Oder damit dieser Sicherheitsdienst ein bisschen aufgewertet wird und niemand mehr fragt, wie viele Jahre Knast denn da habe.
Aber wir schweifen ab. Es ging um die Kennzeichenerfassung. Es gab hier auch in Berlin ein bisschen die Diskussion darum. Da hat auch der Insenator schon gesagt, dass er das eigentlich ganz okay findet, automatische Kennzeichenerfassungssysteme einzusetzen. Und es handelt sich dabei eigentlich um die gleichen Systeme, wie auch jetzt zur Kontrolle der Lkw-Maut aufgestellt worden sind. Und die sind auch schon in Bayern am Grenzübergang probiert worden. Die sind in Thüringen auch schon getestet worden. Und auch Hessen hat schon großes Interesse angemeldet, diese Systeme einzusetzen. Die Idee dabei ist, es wären ganz einfach die Fahrnungslisten, die aktuellen Fahrnungslisten in so ein Gerät eingespeist. Und alle PKWs, die da vorbeikommen, werden dann kontrolliert und gegen diese Fahrnungsliste abgeglichen. So klingt es zumindest jetzt erstmal in einer Theorie. Das Problem ist, dass die Geräte wirklich so leistungsfähig sind, dass sie ohne Probleme den gesamten Verkehr in Deutschland, mit mehreren, also auf die Autobahnen verteilt, komplett erfassen können. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass es auch komplett erst mal gemacht wird. Nur die Systeme sind denn da. Und ja, dann wo es eine Systeme sind, entstehen natürlich auch Begehrlichkeiten. Und ich persönlich glaube nicht, dass so diese Zweckbindung, die da jetzt auch im Autobahnen-Maut-Gesetz vorgesehen ist, dass die auf Dauer ausreicht, dass damit irgendwie kein Schindula, kein Unfug betrieben wird.
Gerade die Unionsinnenminister, die lecken sich doch die Finger danach. Also hör dir doch mal so Leute aus Bayern an.
Ja natürlich, das Autobahnen-Maut-System, das war keine zwei Wochen im Probebetrieb. Da war schon das erste Amtsgericht da und hat schon irgendwie gesagt, ja so Daten hätten wir jetzt mal gerne alle mir.
Ja natürlich. Wir telefonieren nochmal eine Runde, würde ich sagen. Oh Gott, ein paar Menschen, die schon länger warten. Fangen wir an mit Martin aus Aachen. Hallo Martin. Hallo.
Hallo.
Ich wollte zu dem Thema sagen, dass sich natürlich durch die ständige Kameraüberwachung auch das Verhalten der Menschen ändert. Und zwar merke ich das an mir selber, dass ich, wenn ich sag ich mal in ein Kaufhaus gehe, wo ich jetzt genau weiß, dass da zig Kameras auf mich gerät.
Dann close du nicht mehr.
Wie bitte?
Natürlich.
Aber ich verändere mein Verhalten dann irgendwie ganz rigoros. Ich denke die ganze Zeit, ja, wir haben es jetzt nicht zu lange, wir den Deo-Roller angucken, ob ich das jetzt in die Tasche stecke oder nicht, oder wer guckt jetzt gerade zu. Und ich denke, dass es irgendwie langfristig natürlich, wenn das im kompletten öffentlichen Bereich ist, das Verhalten der Menschen total ändern wird.
Also mein Verhalten ändert sich dahingehend, dass wenn ich weiß, ich werde überwacht in einem Kauf, dass verhalte ich mich absichtlich auffällig, um denen auf den Sack zu gehen und hoffentlich hinterher gefragt zu werden, ob ich nicht mal gerade mitkommen könnte und dann schwadroniere ich irgendwie einen von Freiheitsberaubung.
Natürlich, ich warte auch mal darauf, dass mich endlich einer anspricht, ich sollte mal die Tasche auspacken, um dann zu sagen, nein, mach ich nicht. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt dann noch ein ganz witziger Bereich, wenn ich im Kaufhaus bin. Aber es gibt ja noch andere öffentliche Bereiche, wo wir auch ein Recht auf Anonymität haben. Sag ich mal, wie einen Marktplatz, wie öffentliche Straßen. Und da hab ich keine Lust, mein Verhalten zu ändern.
Haben wir das, Nils? Gibt es tatsächlich ein Recht auf Anonymität?
Also, das steht nirgendwo geschrieben. Die Frage ist nur, ob sich das nicht zwangsläufig aus den Grundrechtsartikeln ergibt, die wir eben zu diesem Thema haben. Also, das Persönlichkeitsrecht, das Recht auf freie Entfaltung der Persönlichkeit in Verbindung mit grundlegenden Demokratieprinzipien, würde ich sagen, kann sowas konstruieren im öffentlichen Raum. Ich halte das für rechtlich machbar. Und das ist legitim, das auch zu fordern rechtlich.
Ich denke auch, da wachsen jetzt wieder Generationen auf, die in dem Bewusstsein aufwachsen, dass sie tagtäglich und ständig von Kameras überwacht werden. Ich denke, dass das wirklich das Verhalten und überhaupt irgendwie das Menschenbild dermaßen beeinflusst. Ich denke, wenn ich als Kind schon wüsste, alles, was ich gerade tue, wird überwacht und eventuell sanktioniert, denke ich, dass das nicht dem Menschenbild entspricht, das wir irgendwie haben oder verfolgen sollten.
Das ist super wichtig, weil damit ist sozusagen, du gibst jetzt gerade hier die Begründung für die Verhaltensänderungen, die immer diskutiert wird. Also kommt ja immer der Einwand, die Kamera ändert auch überhaupt nichts und ich hab nichts zu verbergen und das ist alles völlig folgenlos.
Ja, aber das, was du zu verbergen hattest, das legen ja nicht wir fest. Das kann sich ja innerhalb von ein paar Jahren ändern. Ein Terroranschlag wie jetzt in Amerika, in Deutschland und zack, bin ich verdächtig wegen, weil ich jetzt zu viel auf, weiß ich nicht, was weiß ich für Internetseiten rumgesurft bin oder ob ich vielleicht zu lange vor der Moscheeierung gerannt bin.
Genau, genau. Das sind eben so feinere Überlegungen, da muss man einfach ein bisschen subtiler denken und dann wird auch erkennbar, wo das Problem ist.
Ja, ich bin nämlich wie wenig Leute das erkennen und ich bin eigentlich fassungslos, wie Menschen das nicht sehen können, sondern sich darin ergeben und sagen, ich hab nichts zu verbergen und das dient meiner Sicherheit.
Sag mal, diskutierst du mit Bekannten, Verwandten, Freunden darüber, über das Thema?
Im engeren Bereich ja und wo ich kann, natürlich, aber dieses ich hab nichts zu verbergen-Syndrom ist ja natürlich weit verbreitet.
Und wie reagieren die Leute da drauf, wenn du dann sagst, naja, aber wer bestimmt denn, ob sie was zu verbergen haben oder nicht? Oder wenn sich das möglicherweise ändert, wirst du denn da als Paranoid abgetan? Oder glaubst du denn schon, dass da noch was zu retten ist bei den Leuten da draußen?
Ja, ich wundere mich manchmal, aus welchen Bereichen Zustimmung kommt, aus denen ich es gar nicht erwartet hätte und aus anderen Bereichen, denen das völlig egal ist. Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Wie war die Frage?
Hey, das hat in der Schule schon nicht funktioniert.
Ja, das war aber auch eigentlich schon. Ich bin da auch manchmal ratlos bei manchen Leuten. Also ich habe das Glück, dass ich in einem Umfeld lebe, wo zumindest das Bewusstsein bei den meisten Leuten da ist, aber auch nicht bei allen. So oftmals kommt dann auch, naja, das sind so viele Kameras, das kann sich ja sowieso niemand angucken. So sollen sie doch alles filmen, mir doch egal. So guckt sich da sowieso niemand an. Aber es ist halt, wie Jan auch schon gesagt hat, mit der Technik, es geht vorwärts und...
Ja, das Argument kann ich natürlich auch irgendwo verstehen, weil man immer noch denkt, ja, wer soll es alles auswerten? Aber ich denke, die technische Möglichkeit wird kommen und daran wird gearbeitet werden und...
Daran wird gerade massiv gearbeitet.
Also Stichwort Data Mining irgendwie?
Nee, ich wollte eigentlich eher auf irgendwie Gesichtserkennung noch mal hinaus. Ich hab ja vorhin gesagt, dass das zurzeit nicht funktioniert, aber was sie halt gerade tun ist, die Gesichtserkennung mit 3D Kameras bzw. mit Kameras aufnehmen und dann 3D-Profile berechnen. Und die haben inzwischen schon so gute Ergebnisse damit geleistet, dass sie eine Auflösung von 0, 2 Millimetern in alle Richtungen haben. Das heißt, wenn die Systeme einmal einsatzbereit sind, dann können wir uns wirklich nur noch eine Insel suchen oder so. Weil dann können sie wirklich gesamte Bevölkerung glückenlos überwachen.
Alles klar, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf Martin. Interessant noch eine Frage an Nils. Es gibt im Fritz-Board einen Link zur Webcam der Frankfurter Rundschau. Ich hab das gerade mal ausprobiert. Von da aus kannst du wirklich in Fenster in gegenüberliegenden Gebäuden gucken. Mit der Webcam, die hat einen derart geilen Zoom und eine derart geile Auflösung, dass du wirklich Leute hinter Fenstern laufen siehst.
Der vergleichbare Fall, der hat ja in Weimar zu einem Skandal ersten Ranges geführt. Da hat ja der Innenminister von Thüringen eine polizeiliche Videoüberwachung des Marktplatzes eingeführt. Und diese Kamera konnte in die Fenster der Zeitungsredaktion gucken und auch den Eingang der Zeitungsgebäude erfassen.
Und das Büro des Vizepräsidenten.
Was natürlich die Folge hatte, dass ein riesiger Aufschrei in der Presse gab und diese Kamera wieder abgehängt werden musste. Die freie Presse und ihre Informanten.
Mal gucken, wie lange die Frankfurter Rundschau noch eine Webcam betreibt, die man selber schwenken kann.
Wie, die kannst du selber schwenken?
Ja, die kannst du selber schwenken. Hoch, runter, rechts, links und Zoom. Guck mal, hier im Fritz-Bot ist der Link. Muss mal gucken.
Falls ihr noch immer Fragen habt, wie genau diese Kameras sind, welche Auflösung das geht und was man mit alles machen kann, da könnt ihr selber ausprobieren, wie genau die sind.
Ja, also das ist wirklich eindrucksvoll.
Und nicht glauben, dass das alles ist.
Jeder, der jetzt noch sagt, die reden blöd sind, die sich leiten unter Verfolgungswahn, sollte sich das wirklich mal angucken.
Und das ist nur die Hälfte von dem, was geht.
Wenn überhaupt die Hälfte, also ein Achtel, oder? Ein Sechzehntel. Ich biete ein 32. Herzlich willkommen im Radio.
Das hat jetzt wirklich ewig gedauert, naja.
Willst du mitreden oder ich beklagen?
Ich hab was zu sagen, und zwar erstmal Glückwunsch und Danke, dass ihr euch da als CCC für den Datenschutz einsetzt. Ich hab da in den 80ern mal 1984 gelesen und war total entsetzt über dieses Szenario, was da gezeichnet wurde. Und hatte zu der Zeit aber auch noch das Gefühl, dass es in der Öffentlichkeit kontrovers diskutiert wird. Und das hat jetzt irgendwie immer weiter nachgelassen. Die Leute kümmern das nicht mehr so. Dabei sind wir jetzt schon an einem Punkt, den wir uns vor 20 Jahren überhaupt noch nicht ausmalen konnten. Ich hör ja die ganze Zeit Gesichtserkennung, Gesichtserkennung, es geht ja schon, Bewegungserkennung gibt es ja mittlerweile schon. Da kannst du dich als Rosa Helschen verkleiden, da erkenn ich dich immer noch.
Na ja, da ist Recht, oder?
Na ja. Da hilft auch irgendwie Vermummung nichts mehr. Und meiner Meinung nach gehst zum drei Punkte. Erstmal natürlich, wenn du was anstellst, dann weißt du auch selber, was du gemacht hast. Aber natürlich bist du auch interessant, wenn du Geld hast oder kein Geld hast. Oder Geld kostest, besser gesagt. Also jedem, dem nicht klar ist, worum es geht, der kann sich ja mal Gattaca angegucken. Da kann man auch diese Eugenik-Thema mal aus und vor lassen. Also da geht es ja um so Supermenschen und so weiter und die Menschen, die nicht ganz so toll sind. Aber letztendlich geht es ja eigentlich darum, du gehst durchs Leben, suchst einen Job, willst Geld verdienen, willst Geld ausgeben und wenn du dich schauber bist, wenn die Leute ein Profil von dir haben und die Leute wissen, ok, der ist möglicherweise krank oder was, dann kriegst du keinen Job. Wenn die wissen, der hat kein Geld, dann kommst du nicht mehr in deinen Laden rein, wo du rein willst. Nicht mehr in dein Restaurant, weil die wissen, ah, der bestellt nicht das Menü, sondern die Suppe. Solche Dinge, das hat weitreichende Konsequenzen, auch wenn du nichts anstellst.
Das läuft ja gerade schon im einfacheren Sinne. Und zwar Benutzerverhalten überobachten in Supermärkten. Einfach, dass sie ihr Sortiment dahingehend umstellen, weil die Leute an dem und dem Regal länger stehen. Und dann bauen sie ihr ganzes Sortiment dem Kunden entsprechend auf.
So ist es. Wenn du gescannt wirst, wenn die ein Profil von dir haben, du kannst deine Umwelt überhaupt nicht mehr wahrnehmen, wie sie ist, weil dir ständig nur noch was geboten wird, wo andere meinen, das könnte dich jetzt interessieren.
Eine Frage, wie, Jörg, wie machst du das diesen wirklich scheuklappen Leuten klar, die rumlaufen und sagen, das ist alles nicht so schlimm? Ihr seid doch alle Verfolgungswagen. Wie willst du es denen klar machen?
Ja, ich sag mal Radio-Sendung. Das ist mal ein Anfang. Und ja, ich weiß es auch nicht. Also irgendwie, es ist kein Bewusstsein mehr da. In den 80ern war das glaube ich wirklich größer. Da hab ich öfter mal gehört im Fernsehen, ja, der Datenschutz war aufhakt, der hat da Bedenken oder so. Ich weiß auch nicht, von dem hör ich überhaupt nichts mehr. Dann haben sie schon abgeschafft oder was?
Nee, wir haben jetzt aber einen neuen. Aber der Datenschutz wird halt einfach nicht mehr hoch bewertet. Ich meine, gerade nach dem tollen 11. September-Anschlag ist irgendwie alles wichtiger als der Datenschutz.
Wir müssen ihn auch glaube ich in jeder Generation eben auch wieder neu sozusagen erkämpfen. Also es geht immer wieder auch darum, sozusagen das, was nachkommt, muss neu ansetzen.
Mal Hausaufgabe, wahrscheinlich, also es ist ja so, dass zumindest in unserem Land ja immer erst dann ein bisschen was passiert, wenigstens wenn das Kind tief in den Brunnen gefallen ist. So als Hausaufgabe überlegt sich doch mal jeder vielleicht, oder vielleicht hat ja auch der eine oder andere schon eine Idee und will sie ja äußern vielleicht auch am Telefon. Was können wir inszenieren, damit das Kind in den Brunnen fällt? Also wie sähe ein willentliches Szenario aus, einfach wirklich auch den letzten, also wirklich den letzten, ich sag mal, Deppen, der gerade mal seinen Namen fehlerfrei schreiben kann oder sowas, das wirklich auch den letzten darauf hinweist, dass da irgendwo was im Argen liegt.
Mann von Kamera erschlagen.
Da heißt es ja, müsst ihr stärkere Schrauben reinmachen, das ist ja das Problem. Ja, aber das interessiert doch, das ist doch auch, das passiert aber doch mir nicht, ich bestell doch da keine Bücher von Karl Marx. Das ist doch immer das Argument, mir passiert das doch nicht. Das Argument ist doch immer, mir passiert das doch nicht. Ihr seid alle bescheuert, ihr habt alle was zu verbergen. Das ist doch das Argument, was immer kommt.
Es muss schon ausreichen, ich finde der Jörg hat jetzt einen ganz wichtigen Punkt angesprochen, dieses Ausgrenzung. Also das mit Kameras ganz gezielt Leute, zum Beispiel einfach sogenannte Randgruppen aus den Innenstädten, aus diesen schönen Visitenkarten unserer Großstädte entfernt werden. Dass die Kamera dazu dient, Leute Sicherheitspersonal dahin zu steuern und Leute rauszuekelen. Oder eben in Kaufhauspassagen das Hausrecht mit den Kameras durchzusetzen und einfach Leute rauszuekelen. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das wäre doch dann eine Tasche voller Geld und goldener Kreditkarte und völlig zerlumpend im Kaufhaus rumlungern.
Ich finde, die Angela oder Angela hat in ihrer Mail ziemlich gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Sie sagt nämlich, das Ziel dieser ganzen Sache ist, einfach konformes Verhalten zu erzeugen. Und wer dann nicht mitmacht, der hat was zu verbergen.
Und konformes Verhalten heißt in dem Fall halt auch irgendwie auch kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Und deswegen wurde zum Beispiel in Dresden auch ein Teil der Videokameras von Karstadt bezahlt, die das, die die Innenstadt überwachen.
Das ist aber nett von Karstadt.
Total.
Wem hat Karstadt eigentlich gehört, bevor die Nazis es in der eigenen Hand haben?
Ja, also Lösungsvorschlag hab ich leider auch nicht.
Gut, dann vielleicht fällt dir...
Und es gibt mir noch ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass da überhaupt jemand einen Blick drauf hat.
Vielleicht fällt dir ja wirklich was ein. Vielleicht fällt dir wirklich ein, was wir inszenieren könnten, damit wirklich ein echter Eklat passiert. Und vielleicht sogar mal die systemstabilisierenden Medien, die extra in Großbuchstaben schreiben, damit es alle verstehen, auch mal eine Titelgeschichte daraus machen.
Da fehlen uns die Robbenbabys zu.
Aber vielleicht kriegen wir die an.
If it bleeds, it leads.
Joach, danke für deinen Anruf. Tschüss, gute Nacht.
Erstmal Dank nochmal an alle Leute, die geschrieben haben. Ihr schreibt heute wie war es nicht. Wir können natürlich hier nicht alles in der Sendung erwähnen. Wir probieren unser Bestes. Und ich will auch nicht versprechen, dass wir hier jeder mehr einzeln beantworten. Aber auch da probieren wir unser Bestes.
Wer da schreibt und Angst hat, nicht ranzukommen kann, auch anrufen, weil dazu sind wir ja hier. 0331 77 9110 ist die Nummer. Wir sprechen mit euch. So, jedenfalls, meistens. Hallo Matthias. Matthias? Du bist dran, willkommen im Radio.
Zum Thema Chaosrad kommt übrigens auch Sismar. Der hat hier seinen Hauptsitz gehabt. Also aus meiner Stadt, von wo ich anrufe. Na ja, also ich möchte dazu sagen, also ich bin wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen so ein Scheuklappen-Typ. Also ich bin nicht ganz dieser Typ, der sagt rigoros Kameras nein. Ich bin der Meinung, es fehlt eine vernünftige rechtliche Regelung für diese Kamera. Sprich ein Antragsverfahren, in dem ich halt meine Kameras, die ich halt installieren möchte, bei irgendeinem Verantwortlichen oder bei irgendeiner Institution beantragen muss und halt sagen möchte, muss was ich damit vorhabe. Zum Beispiel finde ich diese Sache, was dieser Bahnangestellte uns gesagt hat, von wegen Überwachung der Straßenbahnen und so weiter. Und der Fahrer kann zum Beispiel dann drücken, wenn er jemanden entdeckt, der vielleicht irgendwie Scheiße baut oder sowas. Und den dann zum Beispiel aufzeichnet. Also generell zum Schutz von Eigentum finde ich die ganze Sache nicht schlecht. Allerdings gehören solche Kameras auch im privaten Raum, was so Käuserverhalten angeht und sowas. Also das ist eine Sache, die gehört normalerweise verboten. Da bin ich auch nicht der Meinung, dass das irgendjemandem was nützt. Außer natürlich dem Geschäft. Also grundsätzlich bin ich so zweigeteilt. Also auf der einen Seite bin ich schon der Meinung, dass es durchaus sinnvoll sein kann, solche Videokameras aufzustellen. Gerade, wie gesagt, in Bereichen, ja, also die Bahn, das ist schon ein guter Bereich, weil Sachbeschädigungen und so weiter, das sind natürlich auch immense Kosten. Also das verstehe ich in gewisser Weise auch die Bahn oder sowas. Also keiner möchte, dass die Fahrpreise und so weiter für Bahn weiter steigen. Aber dann auf der anderen Seite will auch keiner die Konsequenzen tragen, um eine höhere Eigentums-Sicherheit zu gewährleisten. Das ist so meine Bedenken. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich dieses englische System ist natürlich in Deutschland auch nicht das, was ich mir vorstelle. Also wenn ich nicht mal über die Straße gehen kann, ohne dass mich jemand beobachtet. Und die Gefahr besteht ja. Sobald eine Kamera mitläuft, besteht halt immer auch die Gefahr, dass jemand anders diese Materialien sichtet. Und eine Idee hätte ich vielleicht auch noch, wie man diese ganze Sache sabotieren kann. Und zwar ist es ganz einfach, also die Kameras werden ja meistens computergesteuert. Man müsste jetzt vielleicht, also es ist jetzt weit hergeholt, aber mit einem guten Hacker, der sich vielleicht in das Computersystem einhackt und dann halt ganz private Bilder von Sinn und Kunst veröffentlicht. Zum Beispiel Schalte im Fernsehen. Was weiß ich, Hans Kunst auf der Straße gefilmt und hier jetzt auf Video. Und dann auch damit im Fernsehen. Also da könnte ich mir dann schon vorstellen, dass die Leute dann sagen halt mal, das bin ich.
Dann freuen sie sich doch, dass sie im Fernsehen sind.
Ja, naja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich freuen, dass sie im Fernsehen sind. Es kommt auf die Situation an, bei der sie gefilmt worden sind.
Das kann aber nicht die Lösung sein. Also es ist nicht schön, wenn man irgendwie Straftaten begehen muss, um irgendwie seine Rechte wahrzunehmen. Also dort ist vorhin ganz zum Anfang irgendwie ein interessanten Ansatz, nämlich dass man die ein bisschen reglementieren kann dadurch, dass halt irgendwie Betreiber von Kameranlagen ihre Anlage anmelden bei irgendeiner zentralen Stelle. Irgendwie im Vorabgespräch hatten wir das Thema, dass das wohl in Norwegen so gehandhabt wird. Ich hab da heute mal versucht im Netz was zu finden, aber leider auch nicht viel gefunden. Der Punkt mit diesem Anmelden, Anmeldeverfahren, da wurden wir sofort sämtliche Leute irgendwie einen erhöhten Bürokratieaufwand vorwerfen. Gerade weil es geht halt um Bürgerrechte und da ist sowieso alles, wo auch nur jemand bemüht werden muss, irgendein Richter, der vielleicht noch die Überwachung unterschreibt. Das ist halt alles Bürokratie und da versuchen sie permanent da weiter abzubauen.
Das Problem ist einfach, man muss ja irgendwo einen Kompromiss finden. Und diese Angstmacherei aufgrund des 11. September, die kann man einfach, man kriegt sie halt aus den Köpfen nicht raus. Und die Medien reiten halt sehr stark auf dieser Masche halt rum. Und natürlich, man muss dann auch irgendwo sagen, wir geben den Leuten halt das Gefühl, dass sie trotzdem noch ein bisschen Angst haben dürfen. Aber es ist halt noch so ein kleiner Tick trotzdem noch Kontrolle der Persönlichkeit dabei. Also Bürokratisierung hin oder her ist zwar schön und gut, aber das Problem ist halt ohne Bürokratisierung dieses ganzen Apparats bekommen wir halt das, was wir überhaupt nicht wollen. Und zwar diese Kontrolle, diese absolute Kontrolle.
Wenn wir es nicht wollten, dann würd's das doch aber doch gar nicht geben, oder? Ich dachte, aller Wille geht von uns aus. Also warum wählen wir, woher kommt das, dass wir immer noch Parteien wählen, die uns sowas aufdrücken?
Welche tuts dann nicht?
Weiß ich nicht. So gut hab ich mich noch nie umgeguckt. Irgendeiner wird sich tun, die APBD wird sicherlich nicht tun.
Also ich mein, nachdem er sogar selbst, nachdem er sogar selbst den PDS hier in Berlin irgendwie sich vorstellen könnte, eine automatische Erfassung von Kennzeichen.
Sie haben es erfunden.
Ja, das nicht jetzt die, die dann davor.
Nee, also ich mein, das ist natürlich problematisch. Und das ist natürlich auch noch nicht der Weitzeitletz, der Schluss mit diesem Beantragungsverfahren. Aber es müsste in irgendeiner Form, zumindest mal einfach mal eine Reglementierung, wo zumindest mal so Eckpunkte festgehalten werden. Das ist zumindest mal auch gerade für Leute, die sich zum Beispiel nicht gerne filmen lassen. Die haben ja zum Beispiel dann auch wieder zumindest mal Punkte, wo sie halt sagen können, okay, also hier sind die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen so und so. Und an diesen rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen können wir uns auch ausrichten. Dann können wir uns halt sicher sein, dass wir zum Beispiel auf öffentlichen Geländen zum Beispiel nicht gefilmt werden, weil es halt von der Behörde niemals genehmigt werden würde. Also das sind zum Beispiel solche Sachen, da könnte ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass man da auch Leute motivieren könnte, da in gewisser Weise mitzugehen und für dieses Thema auch noch ein bisschen stärker sich einzusetzen, weil dann halt einfach wieder, es ist dann halt das Problem, dass man da nicht mehr sagen kann, okay, wir müssen das jetzt alles als gegeben hinnehmen, weil wir haben halt keine Handhabe und bevor ich mich hier aufrege und dann mit meinem Rechtsanwalt reden muss und was weiß ich, um mir halt diese Schere reinmachen, bevor ich mir halt diesen ganzen Stress mache, nimm mich lieber hin und sag mir, ich hab ihn nicht zu verbergen, lauf ich halt weiter.
Ne, Matthias, du hast recht. Das ist wirklich, ja, es ist ein Rechtsproblem. Das Versöhnlichkeitsrecht ist betroffen. Deshalb muss der Gesetzgeber auch da einschreiten. Und wir haben den Wahnsinn, dass wirklich jeder Bereich ist unterschiedlich geregelt. Ob es der Arbeitgeber ist, der am Arbeitsplatz eine Kamera aufhängt, oder ob es ein Kaufhaus ist, was eben seine Kunden überwacht oder auch noch vor der Tür oder ob es die Polizei ist, die ab sofort den Marktplatz überwacht. Überall sind es andere Regelungen. Und diese Regelungen sind windelweich, weil die politisch Verantwortlichen sich nicht trauen, hier sozusagen gegen den Volkswillen hier richtig reinzuhauen. Aber man könnte vieles schon dadurch klarstellen, dass man einfach sagt, zum Beispiel der öffentliche Raum, das öffentliche Straßenland, was sozusagen der Kommune gehört, das bleibt grundsätzlich unüberwacht. Da darf auch kein Privat erfüllen. Und hier ist eine Grenze, dass man doch mal deutliche Grenzen setzt. Und das ist verpasst worden, du hast recht.
Und was natürlich noch viel wichtiger ist, und zwar ist das dann auch ein gutes Argument gegen die Bürokratisierung. Denn was kostet ein Prozess und wie lange, wie viel Zeit nimmt ein Prozess von einzelnen Personen in Anspruch? Wie viele Gerichte werden damit beschäftigt? Wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwo einen Sachbearbeiter hab, der hat klare Richtlinien, und der Sachbearbeiter setzt sich halt hin und sagt, nein, Kamera bekommst du nicht, oder Kamera ist bei dir gerechtfertigt, fertig. Das ist also für mich ein viel geringerer Aufwand, als, was weiß ich, eine Armada von Anwälten zu beschäftigen und tausend Gerichte mit irgendwelchen Lapalien zu beladen.
Na ja, dazu wird es aber doch kommen, wenn natürlich der Hauseigentümer sagt, natürlich ist es für mich gerechtfertigt. Und du sagst halt, trotz einer Nö, das ist nicht gerechtfertigt.
Das ist doch wie überall im Rechtsraum. Das ist zu Anfang, wo die Rechtsprechung ganz klare Grenzen abstecken muss. Das haben wir überall. Das ist jedes Mal, wenn neues Gesetz rauskommt, wird es zu Klagen kommen, wo sich halt Leute darüber beschweren. Dann nimmt die Rechtsprechung das halt auf, klärt das. Und wenn das Ding dann abgegessen ist, dann ist es allgemeines Recht. Und dann ist das Problem auch gelöst. Dann ist das auch in dieser Hinsicht auch geklärt, weil dann jeder klar weiß, wo die Grenzen sind. Das ist mit allem so. Also irgendwann kommt ein neues Gesetz. Da muss halt irgendwer dagegen vorgehen und halt sagen, es packt mir nicht. Dann müssen die Gerichte darüber entscheiden. Dann wird das so gemacht, wie es praktikabel ist und fertig.
Ist denn das bei diesem Thema Videoüberwachung überhaupt praktikabel? Also ist nicht die technische Entwicklung deutlich schneller als irgendwie diese ewig langsamen Mühlen der Justiz?
Nee, ganz so ist es ja nicht. Also das Problem ist ja einfach nur, mehr als aufnehmen kann ich ja nun nicht. Das haben wir ja vorher schon festgestellt, dass diese zum Beispiel Gesichtererkennung und so weiter, das ist ja nun nicht möglich. Na ja, gut Verkehrszeichen, OK, oder Autokehnzeichen, da mag ich so zugestehen, dass das möglich ist. Aber ich mein, was für technische Möglichkeiten sollen da noch kommen? Also nach dem Aufnehmen von Gesichtern und so weiter, was kann da noch kommen?
Noch Geruch, DNA, Fernanalyse, weiß der Geier. Genau, Matthias, wir müssen Nachrichten machen. Genau, wir müssen Nachrichten machen, Matthias. Mit dem Wetter. In der Nacht ist es wolkig, es gibt einzelne Schneeschauer, die Temperaturen sinken auf minus zwei bis minus fünf Grad. Und morgen erwarten uns auch immer mal wieder leichte Schneeschauer bei Temperaturen rund um den Gefrierpunkt. Und jetzt rund um die Meldung mit frischem Sitel.
Ich hab den Namen vergessen.
Ich bin's.
Wer?
Die Meldung. Im Brandenburg hat es im letzten Jahr offenbar mehr Rechte Gewalt gegeben. Das berichtet der Tagesspiegel. Insgesamt habe die Polizei 87 Gewalttaten gezählt. Das waren sechs mehr als im Vorjahr. Die gewaltreiche von Brandstiftung bis hin zum versuchten Mord. Bereitschaftsdienste in Krankenhäusern zählen als Arbeitszeit. Sie müssen aber nicht voll bezahlt werden. Das hat das Bundesarbeitsgericht in Erfurt entschieden. Die Arbeitnehmer würden in diesen Zeiten weniger beansprucht. Deshalb sei es zulässig, dass sie dann auch weniger Geld bekommen. Im Tarifstreit der Metall- und Elektroindustrie soll es ab 0 Uhr in Berlin die ersten Bahnstrecks geben. Die IG Metall hat die Nachtschicht in den Ostrahmwerken entspannender zu Bahnstrecks aufgerufen. Morgen Vormittag sollen da Beschäftigte von Daimler-Cricen an Marienfelde die Arbeit wiederlegen. In Großbritannien gibt es nach dem Abschlussbericht zur Kelly-Affäre die ersten personellen Konsequenzen. Der Vorstandschef, der BBC Davis, hat seinen Rücktritt eingereicht. Die Untersuchung hatte ergeben, dass die BBC im Unrecht war. Sie hatte berichtet, die britische Regierung habe ein Irak-Dossier aufgebaut. Und noch eine Meldung vom Sport. Bei der Handball-Europameisterschaft hat Deutschland gegen Gastgeber Slowenien mit 31 zu 24 gewonnen. Damit reicht den Deutschen morgen ein Unentschieden gegen Ungarn, um ins Halbfinale einzuziehen. Und die gute Meldung vom Verkehr? Keine Meldung.
Solltest du nicht verpassen, Alter. Schon wegen die Gäste. Zum Beispiel Lick. Der Kollege PR Cantata. Also, Mann, Sonntag ist KenFM-Tag. Oder willst du auf dem Schulhof wieder als Loser dastehen, ist dein Leben, Alter.
KenFM, die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Ken Jepsen. Jeden Sonntag von 14 bis 18 Uhr.
Chaosradio 88 ist es, was ihr hört. Es geht um die Überwachung des öffentlichen Raumes mit Kameras. Im Studio von CCC Martin, Jan und Frank und von der humanistischen Union Nils, der ist für die juristischen Fragen zuständig und mit euch am Telefon an der Fritz-Hott-Line.
Hallo Mendy.
Ja, hallo, ich bin Mendy.
Hallo.
Ja, ich hab mich gemeldet, weil ich mich nämlich vielleicht auch sehr ähnlich wie der CCC auch mit Überwachung beschäftige und zwar an der Humboldt-Uni. Wir haben da so ein Seminar für Angewandte Unsicherheit, kurz SAU.
Ein Seminar?
Halt, halt, halt, halt, halt. Ist das ein offizielles Seminar oder ist das?
Das ist eine Initiative von einigen Studierenden, die gedacht haben, hey, das nimmt ganz viel überhand mit der Überwachung und eigentlich sollten wir andere darüber informieren und kritisch anregen, darüber nachzudenken. Und wir zeigen halt Filme dazu zu dem Thema und diskutieren dann im Anschluss danach, beziehungsweise machen Aktionen, um auf das Thema aufmerksam zu machen.
Wie sehen die aus, die Aktionen?
Wie die aussehen. Wir haben zum Beispiel vor Weihnachten vorm Kaufhofen Aktion gemacht gegen diese RFID-Chips und gegen diese Paybackkarten. Und haben dann halt so einen Blatt entworfen, wo drauf stand. Also war halt so gefaked, Kaufhof stand dann drauf mit dem original Kaufhof-Logo, nur halt Kaufhof. Danke, dass sie eingekauft haben und dass sie uns ermöglicht haben und dass wir sie schön überwachen können. Und dann halt so weiter den Text geschrieben und haben dann im Prinzip auf die Rückseite dann noch so ein Bewegungsprofil draufgemalt. Und haben das dann vor dem Kaufhof den Leuten verteilt. Und die Reaktion war halt ziemlich überraschend. Also die Leute waren, wussten das überhaupt gar nicht, dass in diesen Paybackkarten im Prinzip auch kontrolliert werden kann. Was kaufen sie? Wie kaufen sie? Weiblich, männlich? Und das sind halt bestimmte Produkte.
Das wissen die Leute nicht.
Das wissen die Leute nicht, das bestelle ich auch immer wieder fest. Ich entrüste mich ja hinten an der Kasse immer absichtlich. Wenn ich gefragt werde, haben sie eine Paybackkarte, dann machen sie mal ein Riesentammtamm.
Sind sie?
Was wollen sie eigentlich von mir?
Das ist mein Leben.
Einfach um irgendwie dann hinten in der Schlange für Aufruhr zu sorgen. Und die Leute wissen es nicht. Da kommen irgendwie Hausfrauen zu dir und fragen, was machen sie denn für ein, da gibt es doch drei Prozent drauf. Oder da gibt es doch Punkte drauf. Und wenn du denen erklärst, das ist das Schlimmste, was sie nur tun können, weil im Zweifelsfall kriegt ihre Krankenkasse mit, dass sie Zigaretten kaufen. Die fallen aus allen Wolken.
Also es war ja das Lustige, dass sich teilweise ein Leute entrüstet an die Sicherheitsmenschen gewandt haben und die beschimpft haben, wie sie sie überwachen können.
Habt ihr eine Webseite dazu oder so?
Ja, und zwar ist das www.saupunktnet.ms.
MS? Saupunktnet.ms.
Habt ihr über euren Aktionen noch irgendwie Stress bekommen?
Wir haben erst einmal versucht wohl das innen Kaufhof zu machen. Da haben sie natürlich rausgeschickt. Und es ist so sogar so, dass um den Kaufhof drumrum noch teilweise Privatgelände ist. Also wir mussten dann 10 Meter davon noch entfernt gehen. Also das war so einziges, was wir an Stress bekommen haben.
Moment mal, um den Kaufhof drumrum ist noch Privatgelände?
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht so genau, wie sie das begründet haben. Ich glaube schon.
Ja, das ist irgendwie so eine Tendenz, dass halt irgendwie öffentliche Räume privatisiert werden.
Der Potsdamer Platz gehört ja nicht mehr dem Senat.
Der Potsdamer Platz ist glaube ich im Prinzip vollständig in privater Hand.
Gut, aber Grundrechte gelten ja da trotzdem.
Na ja, das kommt drauf an. Also wir hatten ja schon von Nils gehört, dass irgendwie öffentlicher Raum, dass es halt irgendwie eine Vielzahl von Regelungen gibt, die halt irgendwie verschiedene Aspekte im öffentlichen Raum regeln. Und es ist halt auch so, dass es einen Unterschied gibt, also wenn Raum in privater Hand ist, also was so ähnlich aussieht wie eine Straße, beziehungsweise ob es der Kommune gehört. Da gelten halt verschiedene Rechte. Da gilt halt irgendwie der Straßengesetz für Raum in kommunaler Hand und irgendwie die Hausbetreiber können halt ihr Hausrecht ausüben.
Ja, aber das Entscheidende ist natürlich, dass deine Grundrechte da nicht suspendiert sind, sondern dass die möglicherweise bestimmte Einschränkungen erfahren. Aber wenn das für dich als Passanten zum Beispiel gar nicht erkennbar ist, ob das jetzt ein privater oder ein öffentlicher Raum ist, dann muss auch klar sein für dich, dass du dort die Rechte erstmal in vollem Umfang in Anspruch nehmen kannst und sollst. Und es laufen im Augenblick eine ganze Reihe von Prozessen. Das ist ganz interessant, im Augenblick wird gerade sozusagen entschieden, wie es um diese diffusen Räume, diese halböffentlichen, ungeklärten Räume bestellt ist. Es gibt eine ganze Menge von Prozessen. Leute, die demonstrieren wollten in Kaufhauspassagen, Leute, die daran gehindert worden sind, Leute, Gewerkschafter, die Zettel verteilen wollten in solchen Passagen und daran gehindert worden sind. Also da wird im Augenblick...
Darf man das?
Ja, ich bin der Meinung, natürlich darf man das.
Ich würde Ihnen das verbieten.
Ja, das ist eben das, was jetzt versucht wird, vor Gericht zu klären. Das ist damals einfach geschehen. Die haben es einfach durchgesetzt, die privaten Betreiber. Die haben die Leute einfach vor die Tür gesetzt, rausgeworfen mit Sicherheitsdiensten, Gewerkschafter, die im Haus waren.
Das ist also das, was wir davon haben, dass wir angefangen haben, in Shopping-Malls einkaufen zu gehen und nicht mehr zum Händler um die Ecke.
Genau, ich meine, das sind ja nicht nur Privatisierung von ehemals öffentlichen Räumen, sondern es sind einfach neue Räume, die erschlossen worden sind. Bauland, da sind neu erschlossen worden diese Räume. Und die sind heute quasi öffentliche Räume für viele Menschen. Das ist für die das, was früher der Marktplatz in der Stadt war. Man fährt eben an den Stadtrand und fährt in diese Malls und kauft da einen. Das ist quasi der Markt, der ist mal früher in der Innenstadt war.
Oder auch zum Beispiel Bahnhöfe, die sind ja mittlerweile dafür ausgelegt, dass da nicht nur eben eingestiegen, umgestiegen wird, sondern es ist ja wirklich auch ein Marktplatz. Das heißt, die Bahn legt es halt auch darauf an, dass die Leute da zum Shoppen direkt zum Bahnhof hinkommen und damit in ihr Privatgelände reingehen.
Ja, was ich auch nochmal erzählen wollte, also ich habe es schon erzählt zu Studenten. Und es ging ja vorhin um diese Vernetzung, um dieses parkende Auto oder, dass das eigentlich geklaut war. Und da hat er sich ja aufgeregt, dass die Datenvernetzung da nie so funktioniert hat, wie sie funktionieren sollte. Und wir haben jetzt während unserer Studieproteste gemerkt, wie schnell es eben doch geht. Wir hatten ja letzte Woche oder vorletzte Woche so eine Aktion im Abgeordnetenhaus gestartet, wo dann einige Studis sich als Besucherinnen angemeldet hatten und dann von der Tribüne Transparente runtergehängt haben.
Das macht man aber doch auch nicht. Wie bitte? Das gehört sich nicht.
Echt. Und dann haben wir da auch Flyer, haben die da auch Flyer mit runtergeschmissen. Wurden dann natürlich von dem Sicherheitspersonal gleich festgehalten. Und dann kam auch die Polizei und die hat dann zu einigen von denen gesagt, okay, sie kennen wir ja schon. Sie waren doch bei der SPD bundeszentralen Besetzung mit dabei. Die haben während dieser Aktion, die die Innenbund Abgeordnetenhaus gemacht haben, schon gefilmt und haben im Prinzip schon auch Bilder von anderen Besetzungsaktionen parat gehabt, um das dann abgleichen zu können. Und die haben das dann sofort gewusst. Und da ist halt auch noch die Sache, dass man mit so einer Datenabgleichung im Prinzip auch Leute davon abhalten kann, ja, bestimmte Aktivitäten zu machen. Aber gerade diese Polizeifilmung, nämlich diese mobile Filmung, wären diese Demonstrationen zum Beispiel. Dass sie da ja ständig filmen, das war bei diesen Protesten ganz massiv bemerkbar, dass jede Kundgebung, jede Demonstration, jede Aktion, die wir gemacht haben, wurde von der Polizei gefilmt. Und dass die im Prinzip dann auch sofort auswertbar sind. Und damit Leute auch gezogen werden können oder, ja, also wenn sie wissen, dass sie gefilmt wurden, eventuell nicht mehr an bestimmten Aktionen teilnehmen. Weil sie wissen können, okay, das könnte auf mich zurückfallen, weil ich ja gefilmt werde und sich dann im Prinzip den Abstand halten von bestimmten Aktivitäten.
Oder dass du halt vorab auch ausgeschlossen wirst. Ich meine, es sind halt Fälle denkbar, wo du irgendwie zum Castor-Transport fährst und irgendwie 500 Meter vorm Ziel wirst du halt irgendwie rausgewunken, weil da ein Kennzeichen ist.
Das ist nicht nur denkbar, es gab ja dieses Ausreiseverbot, was auf der Limo oder anderen ähnlichen Dateien basiert, wo dann einfach Leute nicht aus Deutschland ausreisen durften.
Das ist doch verfassungswidrig, mich nicht ausreisen zu lassen.
Steht doch nur umso, dass du ein Recht auf Ausreise hast?
Steht das dann nicht? Natürlich. Steht das nicht?
Steht das hier auf einem Grundgesetz?
In dem Falle war es glaube ich sogar so, dass eben die Personalausweise einbehalten wurden von den Personen, die da quasi als angebliche Gewalttäter, als Gewalttouristen identifiziert worden waren von den Behörden. Das ist tatsächlich möglich.
Falls du da irgendwie Lust hast, da irgendwie Kontakt mit dem CCC aufnehmen zu wollen, schreib einfach mal eine Mail an 88.chaosradio.ccc.de. Dann können wir da vielleicht auch in Kontakt kommen. Wenn ihr da irgendwie spezielle Fragen, technische Hintergründe oder sowas noch wissen wollt, vielleicht haben wir das schon.
Ich habe schon Kontakt da gewesen, aber das Angebot ist noch mal zurück.
Alles klar, vielen Dank, Menni.
Tschüss, machs gut. Wir gucken nach Schöneberg zu Barbara. Hallo, Barbara. Bist du schon eingeschlafen? Nee. Du klangst gerade extrem aufgewacht.
Ich habe mich nur gerade nach meinem Telefon gebückt. Okay, ich möchte darauf abstellen und all den naiven Leuten sagen, die meinen, ich habe nichts zu verbergen. Ich habe auch nichts zu verbergen und wehe mich trotzdem dagegen. Weil ich denke, dass das wollen schon ein Anrufer sagte und wohl auch zitiert wurde als E-Mail. Das Wesentliche dabei scheint mir zu sein, irgendwie die Gleichschaltung unserer Hirne, die damit irgendwie angestrebt wird. Weil es ist ja jetzt schon so bei diesen ganzen Überwachungen, das schon klar definiert ist. Ich bin auch nicht vielleicht auf Papier festgehalten, was abweichendes Verhalten ist. Ich gucke mir halt nicht gerne Werbung an, ich gucke mir lieber den Himmel an. Ich stehe vielleicht auf dem Parkplatz und gucke 5 Minuten irgendwelche Wolken an, die da vorbeiziehen und besonders geil aussehen.
Man muss nur aufpassen, dass man hinterher nicht gesiebte Luft atmen muss. Ich wollte schon immer mal gesiebte Luft im Radio sagen.
Oder wenn ich nachts draußen rumlaufe, gucke ich mir halt gern den Himmel an, den Mond, die Sterne, was der Himmel war. Das finde ich sehr viel interessanter als Schausminister von Karstadt. Aber ich denke, es geht darum, dass das Verhalten konformes werden soll. Wir sollen alle durchschnittliche Konsumenten Idioten werden und kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Und jeder, der dem Profil nicht entspricht, der zeigt abweichendes Verhalten und ist damit wahrscheinlich hier inzwischen schon ein potenzieller, ich weiß nicht, Staats- oder sonst was Systemfeind.
Systemfeind, ja genau. Der Staat ist ja eine Demokratie.
Ja, angeblich.
Oder internationale Terrorist.
Islamistischer Netzwerk-Terrorist.
Ich denke auch, das muss man einfach ganz klar sagen irgendwie, dass unser Verhalten tatsächlich auf die Art, auf eine tierisch-sublime Weise verändert wird und man sich deswegen in jedem Fall dagegen wehren sollte. Also da sehe ich irgendwie die Hauptgefahr von den ganzen Dingern und sicher fühle ich mich nirgendwo, wo eine Kamera ist. Ich hab mir auch angewöhnt, wenn immer ich eine Kamera sehe, dann strecke ich erstmal die Zunge raus, und hoffe, dass es irgendwann mal einer sieht. Nee, bislang noch nicht. Also auf der U-Bahn, in der Bank, im Kaufhaus, sobald ich eine Kamera sehe, stelle ich mich hin und hänge die Zunge raus erstmal.
Mich machen die Dinge irgendwie aggressiv. Ich weiß nicht warum, ich kriege immer so einen Hals, wenn ich halt in so einer Kamera grinsen muss, wenn die mich irgendwie anpeilt. Ich finde es einfach richtig scheiße.
Vorsicht! Man muss die Leute aufwecken, die meinen irgendwie, betrifft mich nicht, ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen. Ich habe auch nichts zu verbergen, aber ich möchte bitte das Recht haben, mir auszusuchen, was ich angucke, wo ich wie lange stehen bleibe. Und will mich da nicht gleich schalten lassen. Das ist für mich eine faschistische Tendenz schon. Jeder, der aus irgendeinem Raster, ich weiß nicht, wer Karstadt oder sonst, wer letztlich in der Hand hat oder das Kapital, was die als normal bezeichnen, fällt sich aus dem Raster raus. Bist du schon der Systemfeind? Bist du schon irgendwie...
Na bist du ja auch...
.ausgegrenzt. Ich bin es wahrscheinlich sowieso.
Ja, natürlich. Wenn du sagst, hör auf, dauernd irgendwelchen Strott zu kaufen und dann am besten noch auf Pump, dann bist du ein Systemfeind. Weil wir können nur überleben, wenn alle weiter auf Pump einkaufen.
Ja, ich guck mir echt lieber die Mont-Constellation an.
Ja, Barbara, wir kommen dann gleich mal bei dir vorbei.
Dank dir für den Anruf.
Ja, bitte.
Und trotzdem, jetzt aber ein Vorschlag zur Desensibilisierung der Bevölkerung von Unis aus Wetzlar.
Erzähl, das klingt spannend.
Ja, ich bin auch schon sehr gespannt. Ja, hervorragend. Wir würden jetzt gerne hören, wie wir die Bevölkerung desensibilisieren.
Also ich habe dort einige Ideen, die ich gut halte. Dort hat es eben die Fragen gestellt, wie man am besten das Kind in den Brunnen schmeißt.
Zumindest ein Szenario entwickelt. Also das muss ja nicht wirklich in den Brunnen fallen.
Ja, natürlich. Es geht halt nur darum, also es war eben schon ein gutes Beispiel gebracht worden von der Dame, von der Studentin, die gesagt hat, dass das vor dem Kaufhaus, die den Besuchern, den Kunden, in Papieren die Hand gedrückt haben, auf dem da dieses Szenario abgebildet war, an welchen Orten sie überall eingekauft haben. Also ich finde einfach, ich kenne die meisten Leute, mit denen ich Gespräche über Datensicherheit und Datamining und lauter solche Dinge geführt habe, diese Pupsipunkte, Visa-Cards und Visa alle heißen, was sie machen. Das dort meistens die Reaktionen.
Ey, stopp mal! Ihr könnt hier nicht über Pupsipunkte reden und nicht so anders als ich.
Ganz, ganz großartig. Dietmar Wischmeyer hat eine Schloss in der City, war es, glaube ich, wo er mal so ein bisschen gelästert hat über die Pupsipunkte. Und er verteilt sozusagen Positivpunkte an Leute, die ihm irgendwie nicht belästigen mit irgendwelchen Kartenscheißen.
Okay, entschuldige bitte, Jürgen.
Nee, kein Problem.
Ja, und dass die Leute, wenn ich denen klarmachen wollte, dass doch eigentlich ein bisschen weitgreifender und problematischer ist, die ganze Sache, die vonstatten geht. Also bei den Kameras, das führt ja eigentlich alles auf das gleiche Problem zurück. Ja, Datenzentralisierung von zu sensiblen Daten. Und irgendwann weiß auch keiner mehr, wenn mal der Erheber von den Daten nicht mehr da ist, was dann damit gemacht wird. Es führt ja eigentlich alles aufs gleiche Problem zurück. Und den Leuten das etwas besser begreifbar zu machen, dann an der Stelle finde ich es einfach gut, wenn man personennah Beispiele bringt. Ja, und das sind so Dinge wie zum Beispiel der Krankenkasse. Und wenn man den vor Augen hält, vielleicht auch weiß, ob sie eine Krankheit haben oder ähnliches, was mit diesen Informationen in der falschen Hand geschehen könnte. Da wurden ja auch schon, glaube ich, von einigen Anrufern Dinge, Beispiele gebracht, dass halt irgendwelche Kredite bei Banken nicht mehr gegeben werden oder arbeitet.
Der alte Trick, das je nachdem, wo du wohnst, darfst du eben auf Rechnung eine Bestellung durchführen beim Quelleversand oder darfst du es eben nicht?
Ja, und es ist ja eigentlich noch viel weitgreifender. Es sind ja Dinge, die analog auf viele Bereiche übertragen werden können. Und wenn solche Szenarien den Leuten entsprechend dargelegt werden, als vielleicht irgendwelche Fachleute sich über die rechtlichen Dinge, also den rechtlichen Rahmen mit irgendwelchen terminologischen Dingen unterhalten und einfach, dass die Leute gar nicht verstehen, worum es genau geht, und kein Übersetzer vorhanden ist, dass dann auch keine Sensibilisierung in der Bevölkerung stattfinden kann. Und der Preis der Freiheit ist ja die Wachsamkeit. Und das Einzige, womit man denke ich mir das Potenzial schaffen kann, ist mit der Bevölkerung. Wenn kleinere Gruppen, die das Ganze noch etwas am Laufen halten, nur agieren, dann ist das etwas problematisch, finde ich. Ja, also ich finde das, um auf den Punkt zu bringen, personenbezogene Beispiele zu bringen und darauf mehr Wert zu legen und damit also die Bevölkerung zu mobilisieren.
Alles klar, vielen Dank, Junich.
Ja, und noch eine Sache. Jemand hat eine Frage gestellt, Entschuldigung. Partner von Polizei. Ich habe auf der Homepage vom Landeskriminalamt habe ich ein Warnungsbild.
Welches LKA? Du kommst aus Wetzlar. Das ist glaube ich ein anderes Bundesland.
Ja, nee, es war auch nicht von Hessen. Wetzlar ist in Hessen. Ich weiß nicht von welchem Bundesland es jetzt genau war. Jedenfalls war dort eine Warnung, dass einige Betrüger, kann man schon sagen, Briefe versenden mit kommerziellen Zweck und dort Begriffe wie Partner von Polizei.
Habe ich doch gesagt, die kleben das auf ihre Autos, damit keiner mehr fragt, was da Verbrecher überhaupt arbeiten müssen.
Okay, der Typ, der sie bewachen soll, ist ein Totschläger und Drogenhändler.
Und dann noch das Emblem von der Polizei einbinden. Und dann hat die Polizei darauf hingewiesen, dass das rechtlich nicht verboten werden kann. Und somit die Betrüger, den Opfern suggestieren wollen, dass sie von der Polizei beauftragt sind oder sehr nahe der Polizei stehen. Und somit auch mehr Seriösität.
Das trifft bestimmt auf das Sicherheitsunternehmen zu.
Kann man das vielleicht auch damit in Verbindung bringen, dass dieses Unternehmen oder was auch immer das war, wenn man es Unternehmen nennen kann, vielleicht einfach auch in dem Sinne Werbung, versucht Werbung zu machen, wäre eine Möglichkeit. Aber zumindest das Partner von Polizei und dem Symbol, Partnerpolizeiempfehlen habe ich auf der Homepage, habe ich diesen Artikel auf der Homepage gelesen.
Großartig, vielen Dank. Dann haben wir noch eine Mail gekriegt, wie man denn auch noch mal ein bisschen Zinnova machen kann. Also nicht nur bei Payback rumjammern oder Alarme auslösen, sondern einfach mal, wenn der U-Bahn kontrolliert wird, anzweifeln, dass die Ausweise der Kontrollettis echt sind.
Das Schöne ist, wie man die so ein bisschen ärgern kann. Die BVG hat nämlich in ihrer letzten aktuellen Kundenzeitschrift selber irgendwie erklärt, wie diese Ausweise aussehen sollen, wie die echten denn aussehen, und sie erklären auch, dass es halt einmal die BVG-eigenen Leute gibt, und dass es Leute gibt in den Firmen, die also im Auftrag der BVG die Fahrscheine kontrollieren. Und dann steht auch drin, dass man sich von denen natürlich auch die richtigen Firmenausweise zeigen lassen kann. Also nicht nur diesen Auftrag im Auftrag der BVG, den normalen Kontrolleursausweis, sondern zusätzlich auch noch deren Firmenausweis, wenn man ganz sicher gehen will. Und natürlich will man ganz sicher gehen.
Ja, wir sind quasi am Ende jetzt, nicht?
Wir könnten, glaube ich, bestimmt noch 5 Sendungen zum Thema machen.
Das werden wir doch sicherlich auch die nächsten Jahre noch, oder?
Bestimmt. Schreibt noch irgendwie, wenn ihr Mails habt, wenn ihr noch irgendwas irgendwie uns sagen wollt. Wir werden, glaube ich, diesmal so viel an Sachen noch offen. Ich glaube, wir machen diesmal wieder so ein Update. Wird wohl nichts vor dem Wochenende werden, aber ich verspreche hoch und heilig, dass wir da was rumschicken. Geht auf chaosradio.ccc.de und lest da nach, wie ihr unseren Newsletter, unseren Chaosradio-Ticker abonnieren könnt, damit ihr immer auf dem Lauf hingehalten werdet, wann die nächste Sendung ist, damit ihr keine Sendung vergesst. Die Sendung gibt es ja auch als Aufzeichnung in ein paar Tagen auf unserem FDP-Server.
Ja, das war's Chaosradio 88. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen. Vielen Dank, Jungs, dass ihr hier wart. Den Nils werden wir möglicherweise Mitte Februar schon wieder hören, denn wir haben uns überlegt, eine Sendung zu den Bürgerrechten zu machen, wie es da so aussieht, der aktuelle Stand ist. Guckt einfach auf die Fritz-Homepage, da werdet ihr dann lesen, ob und wann diese Sendung stattfindet. Vielen Dank. Ja, viel Spaß am Gerät natürlich. Jetzt auf eins der Nightfly mit Martin Petersdorf.